SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ALVARADO, GIL. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ DEL DODD. DURAZZO. EGGMAN
GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE. HURTADO
JONES. LAIRD. LIMON. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN. NGUYEN
NILO. OCHOA. BOGUE. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMMER. WAHAB WIENER. WILK
A QUORUM IS PRESENT. COLLEAGUES
IF WE COULD KINDLY RETURN TO OUR
DESK. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
GUESTS BEHIND THE RAIL. BEYOND
THE RAIL. PLEASE STAND UP. WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR ARCHULETA.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COSMOLOGIST BRIAN
SWIMME SAYS THIS MUST BE A
CENTRAL FACET OF HUMAN EXISTENCE
TO HAVE THE TRUTH RIGHT IN FRONT
OF US AND YET TO BE UNABLE TO
RECOGNIZE IT. SO TODAY, WE PRAY.
GRACIOUS AND LOVING GOD, WE
THANK YOU FOR THE GIFT OF SIGHT
AND INSIGHT THAT GIVE DEPTH AND
MEANING TO OUR LIVES. SLOW US
DOWN, THAT WE MAY SEE THE BEAUTY
THAT SURROUNDS US UNDER THE BLUE
SKY AND IN THE FACET AND IN THE
FACE OF EACH PERSON WE MEET.
HELP US TO SEE BEYOND
APPEARANCES, TO THE MYSTERY AND
THE POTENTIAL IN ALL THAT HAS
BEEN CREATED. MAY WE RECOGNIZE
THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF FEAR AND
SELF-INTEREST AS WE EFFECTIVELY
LOOK FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO SERVE
THE COMMON GOOD. GRACIOUS GOD,
WE TRUST THAT YOU SEE DEEPLY
INTO OUR HEARTS AND LOVE WHAT
YOU SEE. AMEN MEMBERS AND
GUESTS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOU'RE ALL
LOOKING VERY PATRIOTIC TODAY. WE
HAVE UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WERE
DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WERE DEEMED READ, AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED UNDER MOTIONS
, RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR MAY 13TH, 2024
THROUGH MAY 16TH, 2024 WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. HERE WE GO. WE'RE
GOING INTO THE MEETING PART OF
OUR SESSION. CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. UNDER SECOND
READING FILE. WE HAVE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH 114. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL NINE 6987 1380
1468 895 896 897 899 905.
READING WERE DEEMED RED. HERE WE
GO. SENATORS SENATE, THIRD
READING. ARE WE READY? WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
124. SENATOR CORTEZ, ARE YOU
PREPARED? SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 956 BY SENATOR
CORTEZ AND ACT RELATING TO
SCHOOL FACILITIES. THANK YOU,
MADAM SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB 956, WHICH
REAUTHORIZES K-12 DISTRICTS TO
USE THE DESIGN BUILD DELIVERY
METHOD WHEN CONSTRUCTING AND
DESIGNING SCHOOL FACILITIES.
IT'S A UNIQUE PROJECT DELIVERY
METHOD. AS MOST OF YOU KNOW, IT
ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO SELECT THE
DESIGN, PROFESSIONAL AND
CONTRACTOR CONCURRENTLY THROUGH
A SINGLE CONTRACT BY
ESTABLISHING A GUARANTEED
MAXIMUM PRICE FOR THE PROJECT.
THE METHOD REDUCES THE RISK OF
COSTS, INCREASE ONCE
CONSTRUCTION BEGINS. THIS BILL
ALSO REMOVES THE SUNSET
ALTOGETHER, BECAUSE SCHOOLS HAVE
PROVEN OVER TWO DECADES THAT
THEY CAN USE THIS DESIGN BUILD
METHOD RESPONSIBLY TO THE
BENEFIT OF THEIR COMMUNITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE SENATORS. ANY DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM FOR ITEM
124. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. BORG. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
SKINNER. SMALL SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMMER. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
DALLEY GROVE. NÓ. JONES MIN.
WHEN NILO. NO. SATO NO. WHEN. NO
. TAKING A PAUSE. SENATORS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
DALLEY JONES. MIN. AYES 32. NOES
FIVE. MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING
ON TO ITEM 128. SENATOR
CABALLERO, YOU PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1386 BY SENATOR CABALLERO.
AN ACT RELATING TO EVIDENCE.
PLEASE PROCEED. SENATOR THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1386, A BILL THAT WOULD CLARIFY
THE CIVIL RAPE LAW, A LAW THAT
PROTECTS THE PRIVACY OF
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT,
RAPE AND SEXUAL BATTERY BY
PROHIBITING AT TRIAL INQUIRIES
REGARDING THEIR SEXUAL
HISTORIES. THIS BILL IS BASED ON
THE EXPERIENCE OF A JANE DOE, AN
EIGHT YEAR OLD GIRL WHO WAS
SEXUALLY ABUSED OVER A ONE YEAR
PERIOD FROM 2009 TO 2010 BY HER
FOURTH GRADE TEACHER. WHILE AT
SCHOOL. THREE YEARS LATER, THE
SAME VICTIM WAS SEXUALLY ABUSED
BY A FAMILY FRIEND AT HOME.
THEREAFTER, SHE RECEIVED
COUNSELING FOR HER TRAUMA AND
SHE REPORTED HER PRIOR SEXUAL
ABUSE AS WELL. THE TRIAL COURT
RULED THAT EVIDENCE OF THE
SUBSEQUENT SEXUAL ASSAULT
SUFFERED BY JANE DOE COULD BE
ADMITTED AS EVIDENCE TO
UNDERMINE HER CREDIBILITY. IN
REVIEWING THE TRIAL COURT'S
DECISION, THE CALIFORNIA COURT
OF APPEALS AND THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT RULED THAT THE
DEFENDANT'S SCHOOL DISTRICT MAY
SEEK TO ADMIT EVIDENCE OF A
SURVIVOR'S OTHER SEXUAL CONTACT
CONDUCT TO IMPEACH THE
SURVIVOR'S CREDIBILITY. MEMBERS
FORCING SURVIVORS TO DISCLOSE
DETAILS ABOUT THEIR INTIMATE
LIFE OR TO RELIVE TRAUMATIC
INCIDENTS UNRELATED TO THE CASE
IN ORDER TO UNDERMINE THEIR
CREDIBILITY, CAN BE AS
TRAUMATIZING AS THE ASSAULT
ITSELF. RAPE SHIELD LAWS ARE
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO PROTECT
SURVIVORS FROM AN UNNECESSARY
AND INTRUSIVE INQUIRIES INTO
THEIR PERSONAL LIVES, AND SEXUAL
HISTORIES. SB 1386 WOULD CLARIFY
THAT EVIDENCE OF A VICTIM'S
SEXUAL CONDUCT UNRELATED TO THE
CASE IS NOT ADMISSIBLE TO
IMPEACH THE TESTIMONY AS TO
CONSENT OR DAMAGES OF THE
VICTIM. THIS BILL WILL PRESERVE
THE INTEGRITY OF THE CIVIL RAPE
SHIELD LAW AND FOSTER A
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR
SURVIVORS TO COME FORWARD AND
SEEK THE JUSTICE THEY DESERVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON FILE ITEM 128?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI AYE.
DODD. AYE. Dð RUSSELL. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
WHEN I. NILO OCHOA. BOGH AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMMAT.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE WIENER. AYE.
WILK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MIN NILO. AYE. WILK AYE
. ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE
MEASURE CARRIES. MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
130. THIS IS SB 1091. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1091 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. ENACT RELATING
TO SCHOOL FACILITIES. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. SB
1091 IS SEEKING TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO SCHOOL GROUNDS GREENING
PROJECTS BY CAPPING THE REQUIRED
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE PATH OF
TRAVEL TO 20% OF THE ADJUSTED
CONSTRUCTION COSTS OF THE
PROJECT, IN LINE WITH FEDERAL
CURRENT FEDERAL ADA LAW.
CHILDREN, ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ATTEND SCHOOLS IN URBAN AREAS
THAT ARE ILL EQUIPPED TO SHELTER
STUDENTS FROM EXTREME HEAT LIKE
THOSE IN MY DISTRICT, ARE AT AT
HEIGHTENED RISK OF SUFFERING
HEAT RELATED ILLNESSES, POOR
HEALTH AND LEARNING OUTCOMES.
LACK OF TREES AND NATURAL AREAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
COMMUNITIES WITH THE LOWEST
INCOMES. CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW
REQUIRES SCHOOL GRANT GREENING
PROJECTS THAT REMOVE ASPHALT,
PLANT TREES, AND CREATE NATURE
BASED OUTDOOR LEARNING SPACES TO
BRING THE PATH OF TRAVEL TO THE
PROJECT UP TO CODE WITHOUT A
LIMIT ON THE COST. THIS
REPRESENTS A TREMENDOUS BARRIER
TO GREENING SCHOOL GROUNDS,
BECAUSE EVEN A SMALL PROJECT CAN
TRIGGER EXPENSIVE UPGRADES. OUR
STATE GRANTS CURRENTLY OFFER THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
20% UPGRADES TO ADA, ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING, BUT
ESSENTIALLY NEGATES THE SCHOOL'S
ABILITY TO UPGRADE THEIR SCHOOL
CAMPUSES TO BE MORE GREEN. THE
2022 CALIFORNIA EXTREME HEAT
ACTION PLAN RECOGNIZES THE
URGENCY OF COOLING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES, AND PROMOTES THE
USE OF NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS.
IT WILL SUPPORT THE ACCESS THE
ACCESS NEEDS OF ALL STUDENTS
WHILE KEEPING CALIFORNIA'S
POLICY IN LINE WITH FEDERAL
ACCESSIBILITY LAWS. RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
SENATOR OCHOA. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. JUST A QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR. WILL YOU TAKE A
QUESTION? YES. MR. PRESIDENT,
PLEASE PROCEED, JUST ANY
COMMUNICATIONS WITH REGARDS TO
THE FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THESE, REQUIREMENTS
BY THE SCHOOL DISTRICT. HAS
THERE BEEN ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SO MR. PRESIDENT,
THROUGH THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
PRESIDENT, THERE IS NO MANDATE
REGULATION FOR THE SCHOOL, UNDER
THIS BILL, THIS WOULD THIS IS
ONLY ASKING WHEN THE SCHOOL
APPLIES FOR A GRANT THAT THEY
ONLY NEED TO UPGRADE THE PATH OF
TRAVEL TO 20% OF ADA. SO THERE'S
NO MANDATE, THIS IS, THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT. IT'S ONLY WHEN THEY
APPLY. VERY GOOD. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SENATOR MENGIBAR, YOU MAY
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. Dð. RAFEAL. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO ACIERTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE WIENER. AYE.
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. AGUILAR
DALLI. AYE. GROVE AYE. MIN ON A
VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE. THE
MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, THESE ARE
THE NEXT THREE BILLS WE'RE GOING
TO BE TAKING UP FOR ITEM 131.
FILE ITEM 135, AND FILE ITEM
139. SO YOU'RE PREPARED STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM 131. SENATOR
BRADFORD, ARE YOU READY?
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1177 BY SENATOR BRADFORD,
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
UTILITIES. SENATOR BRADFORD,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. SB
1177 UPDATES CALIFORNIA'S
UTILITY SUPPLIER DIVERSITY LAW
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND SPIN
CONCENTRATION AND FOSTER A MORE
DIVERSE WORKFORCE, BETTER KNOWN
AS GENERAL ORDER. 156 CALIFORNIA
UTILITY SUPPLIER DIVERSITY LAW
IS ONE OF THE LARGER ENGINES OF
SOCIOECONOMIC MOBILITY FOR
HISTORICALLY DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESSES AND PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. 40 YEARS
AGO, WHEN THE LATE ASSEMBLYWOMAN
GWEN MOORE INTRODUCED A MEASURE
THAT ESTABLISHED GENERAL ORDER
156, IT WAS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT OUR UTILITIES CONTRACTED
WITH WOMEN OWNED, MINORITY OWNED
AND DISABLED VETERAN OWNED
BUSINESSES AT THAT TIME. 40
YEARS AGO, THE SPIN WAS LESS
THAN ONE HALF $1 MILLION. TODAY.
TODAY THEY THE SPIN IS OVER $18
BILLION. BUT WHAT WE HAVE FOUND
IS THAT THOUGH THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
HAS GONE UP, THE NUMBER OF
BUSINESSES HASN'T INCREASED. AND
WHAT WE'VE ALSO FOUND OUT THAT
WHAT WAS ONCE MEN OWNED
BUSINESSES IS NOW WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES OWNED BY THEIR WIVES
OR THEIR DAUGHTERS. AND THIS
BILL SIMPLY ALLOWS US TO TRACK
THE DATA AND FIND OUT HOW MANY
WOMEN OWNED, VETERAN, DISABLED,
VETERAN OWNED OR MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES. THE UTILITIES ARE
DOING BUSINESS WITH. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
AND ANY DISCUSSION OR OR DEBATE
ON ITEM 131. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL WAS. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMMER AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TALLY
MEN. JONES. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA.
CIERTO WILK. AYE EYES, EYES. 33.
NÓ. ZERO. MEASURE CARRIES FIVE.
ITEM 135. THE SENATOR IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1484 BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEBAS AN ACT
RELATING TO JUVENILES. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT, AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB 1484 AND WOULD LIKE
TO THANK OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL,
ROB BONTA, WHO IS SPONSORING
THIS BILL, AS WELL AS HIS STAFF
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF
THEIR HARD WORK. IN 2018, THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB 439, WHICH
WAS INTENDED TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN BY
COMPLETELY LIMITING THE JUVENILE
COURT'S JURISDICTION IN CASES
INVOLVING YOUTH UNDER THE AGE OF
12. WHILE THE INTENT OF THE BILL
WAS TO ENTIRELY PREVENT YOUTH
UNDER AGE 12 FROM CONTACT WITH
THE COURT SYSTEM, UNINTENTIONAL
OMISSIONS IN THE WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE HAS LEFT THESE
CHILDREN VULNERABLE TO EXPEDITED
AND INFORMAL PROCEDURES.
ADJUDICATING YOUTH CHARGED FOR
NONVIOLENT CRIMES. THIS
UNINTENTIONAL OMISSION HAS
CREATED CONFUSION REGARDING THE
MINIMUM AGE LIMITS OF YOUTH, WHO
MAY BE SUBJECT TO SUCH INFORMAL
OR EXPEDITED PROCESSES. THIS
BILL WOULD CLARIFY THAT THE AGE
RESTRICTIONS ENACTED IN SB 439
ALSO APPLY EVEN IN THE CONTEXT
OF INFORMAL OR EXPEDITED
PROCEEDINGS. THESE INFORMAL AND
EXPEDITED PROCEEDINGS LOOK
DIFFERENT THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
BUT IN SOME COUNTIES, YOUTH MAY
BE REFERRED TO INFORMAL TRAFFIC
COURTS OR PROCEEDINGS BEFORE
JUVENILE HEARING OFFICERS. IN
THESE PROCEEDINGS, YOUTH MAY NOT
BE APPOINTED A PUBLIC DEFENDER
OR A COURT REPORTER. YOUTH IN
THESE PROCEEDINGS MAY FACE
SIGNIFICANT FINES AND PENALTIES.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
AGREED THAT OUR CHILDREN UNDER
THE AGE OF 12 DO NOT BELONG IN
OUR COURTS, SB 1484 IS A
COMMONSENSE CLARIFICATION THAT
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF 12
MUST BE PROTECTED FROM THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF JUSTICE
SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT, EVEN IN
INFORMAL AND EXPEDITED
PROCEEDINGS, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES. LAIRD AYE. LEMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NILO NO.
OCHOA. BOGUE PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEGATO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES MINH. NGUYEN
NO. OKUBO NO. AYES 31. NO. SIX.
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW. MOVING
ON TO ITEM 139. SENATOR ASHBERY,
ARE YOU PREPARED? SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1058 BY
SENATOR ASHBY AND ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1058.
THE PARK RANGERS PROTECTIONS
ACT. THIS BILL EXTENDS WORKER'S
COMPENSATION AND DISABILITY
PROTECTIONS TO COUNTY AND
SPECIAL DISTRICT PARK RANGERS,
PARK RANGERS SERVE CALIFORNIA
PRIDE PROTECTING REGIONAL PARKS,
WILDLIFE AND THE PUBLIC VISITING
THOSE PARKS. OFTENTIMES, PARK
RANGERS ARE THE FIRST POINT OF
CONTACT FOR DISTURBANCES FACING
SIMILAR RISKS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SACRAMENTO COUNTY
PARK RANGERS HAVE MADE 241
ARRESTS IN THIS YEAR ALONE,
INCLUDING 61 FELONIES. DESPITE
ALL OF THIS, PARK RANGERS ARE
NOT GIVEN THE SAME WORKER'S
COMPENSATION AND DISABILITY
PROTECTIONS GRANTED TO OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. SB 1058
CREATES PARITY FOR COUNTY AND
SPECIAL DISTRICT PARK RANGERS BY
GRANTING THEM WORKER'S
COMPENSATION AND DISABILITY
PROTECTIONS. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS AND
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GIL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. HURTADO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NILO AYE. OCHOA. BORG
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GIL DALLEY. GROVE AYE.
MEN, WHEN AN AYE. AYES 37. NO.
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT
THREE WE HAVE UP ARE FOR ITEM
ONE 4143 AND 144. WE'LL START
OFF WITH ITEM 140. THE SENATOR
IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1445 BY SENATOR
CORTEZ. AN ACT RELATING TO
SCHOOL GOVERNANCE. PLEASE
PROCEED. SENATOR. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
1445, SENATE BILL 1445 WILL
ENABLE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO ALLOW THEIR
STUDENT BOARD MEMBER TO RECEIVE
LIMITED CASE INFORMATION,
SEPARATE FROM A CLOSED SESSION
MEETING, WITH THE CONSENT OF THE
STUDENT FACING EXPULSION AND
THEIR PARENT OR GUARDIAN TO
PROVIDE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE.
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE LARGER
BOARD'S CONSIDERATION IN THEIR
CLOSED SESSION MEETING. ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE STRIDES IN
RECENT YEARS TO ADDRESS OVERLY
PUNITIVE ACTIONS IN SCHOOLS, LOW
INCOME STUDENTS, STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR ARE STILL EXPELLED AT
HIGHER RATES COMPARED TO THEIR
PEERS BY PASSING THIS BILL, WE
WILL BE REINFORCING RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PRINCIPLES IN OUR
SCHOOLS, STRENGTHENING
CONNECTIONS AMONG EFFECTIVE
INDIVIDUALS, PEERS, TEACHERS AND
THE WIDER SCHOOL COMMUNITY. THE
BILL HAS NO NO KNOWN OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NÓ. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMMER AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEN WHEN. NØ. NILO AYE. AYES 34
NOES. FIVE. MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM 143. I SEE THE
SENATOR IS READY. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1290 BY
SENATOR ROTH. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. SENATOR
ROTH. THANK YOU. SENATORS. THIS
BILL SUNSETS CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS. BENCHMARK PLAN. THE
BENCHMARK PLAN IS THE PLAN THAT
SETS THE BENEFIT STANDARDS FOR
ALL OF THE HEALTH PLAN AND
INSURANCE POLICIES THAT ARE SOLD
IN CALIFORNIA'S INDIVIDUAL AND
SMALL GROUP HEALTH INSURANCE
MARKETS, ACCORDING TO THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT, WHICH OF
COURSE INCLUDES PLANS THROUGH
COVERED CALIFORNIA FEDERAL RULES
ALLOW STATES TO UPDATE THEIR
BENCHMARK PLAN AFTER UNDERGOING
A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. THE RULES
ALSO ESTABLISH A COST CEILING
AND FLOOR FOR THE CHANGES THAT
CAN OCCUR. THIS BILL IS MEANT TO
START THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
FOR A NEW ESSENTIAL BENEFITS
PLAN. AN ACTUARIAL ANALYSIS WILL
BE COMPLETED AND STAKEHOLDER
DISCUSSIONS BOTH HERE AND IN THE
ASSEMBLY WILL TAKE PLACE BEFORE
FINAL DECISIONS ARE MADE AND
FINAL VOTES ARE TAKEN. WE CAN
AND SHOULD EVALUATE OUR
BENCHMARK PLAN TO ENSURE THAT
THE BENEFIT STRUCTURE REFLECTS
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS, BUT
WE CAN'T MAKE CHANGES TO THE
PLAN WITHOUT WORKING THROUGH
THIS PROCESS. ULTIMATELY, BY
UPDATING THE PLAN, WE MAY BE
ABLE TO ADD NEW NEEDED BENEFITS
WITHOUT IMPACTING THE GENERAL
FUND. WITH THAT, ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, DO
WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SENATOR GROVE, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. I TOO, RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1290. I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK AT
NEW BENEFITS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDED TO THE PROGRAM, BUT ALSO
HAVE TO HAVE A MECHANISM IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY FOR THEM AND
ELIMINATE MAYBE THINGS THAT WE
DON'T NECESSARILY USE ON A
REGULAR BASIS THAT WERE COVERED
A FEW YEARS AGO, RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE FOR THEIR
DISCUSSION. SENATOR ROTH, YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FOR HER KIND REMARKS AND ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE. OCHOA
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO SATO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMMER. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. JONES. AYE LIMON. MIN
RUBIO. AYE WARMER TIES.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. LIMON. AYE MEN.
AYES 39. NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. ALL RIGHT. NEXT 3 OR 5.
ITEM 144, 145 AND 148. IF YOU
WANT TO PREPARE FOR ITEM 144.
MAJORITY LEADER, ARE YOU
PREPARED? SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1308 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ AND AQUILINO TO AIR
POLLUTION MAJORITY LEADER. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT, AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB 13 ZERO EIGHT, WHICH WILL
ENSURE THAT INDOOR AIR CLEANING
DEVICES CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
RESPIRATORY CONDITIONS. AIR
CLEANERS ARE EFFICIENT TOOLS
THAT IMPROVE INDOOR AIR QUALITY,
AND SB 1308 WILL ADDRESS THIS
RISK BY DIRECTING CARB TO ADOPT
A MORE STRINGENT OZONE EMISSION
STANDARD THAT LIMITS EMISSIONS
TO NO HIGHER THAN FIVE PARTS PER
BILLION FOR INDOOR AIR CLEANING
DEVICES, TO ENSURE THAT THESE
DEVICES CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS WITH RESPIRATORY
ILLNESSES AND CONDITIONS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON ITEM 144?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI NÓ. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
NO. OCHOA. BOGUE PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE
NO. MIN. NGUYEN OCHOA. EBCLC
AYES 32 NOES FIVE MEASURE
PASSES. FARNHAM 145. SENATOR
ARCHULETA, YOU'RE PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1335 BY SENATOR ARCHULETA.
AN ACT RELATING TO CALIFORNIA
CADET CORPS. SENATOR, YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATE BILL 1335 WILL
ENHANCE THE GROWTH OF THE
CALIFORNIA CADET CORPS AND WILL
PERMIT ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIA
CADET CORPS PROGRAMS TO BE
ESTABLISHED, ENSURING MORE YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
LIFE CHANGING PROGRAM. THE
CALIFORNIA CADET CORPS IS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S ONLY
SCHOOL BASED APPLIED LEADERSHIP
PROGRAM CONDUCTED WITHIN A
MILITARY FRAMEWORK, WHICH ALSO
INCLUDES CIVILIAN TEACHERS AND
INSTRUCTORS. THE PROGRAM
PROVIDES PERSONAL GROWTH,
LEADERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES, AND
PUBLIC SERVICE VOCATIONAL
PATHWAYS FOR APPROXIMATELY 6000
CADETS IN MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH
SCHOOL. THE CALIFORNIA CADET
PROGRAM ESTABLISHES A MILITARY
FRAMEWORK AT EACH PARTICIPATING
SCHOOL THAT DEVELOPS LEADERSHIP
SKILLS, ENHANCES ACADEMIC AND
VOCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT, FOSTERS
GOOD CITIZENSHIP AND PATRIOTISM,
ENCOURAGES HEALTH, WELLNESS, AND
FITNESS. ALTHOUGH ARRANGED IN A
MILITARY FRAMEWORK TO MAXIMIZE
THE LEADERSHIP EXPERIENCE FOR
THE CADETS, THE PROGRAM DOES FAR
MORE THAN INTRODUCE MILITARY
EXPERIENCE AND CONCEPTS. CADETS
ARE ROUTINELY AWARDED FULL
COLLEGE SCHOLARSHIPS, SERVICE
ACADEMY APPOINTMENTS. SENATE
BILL 1335 WILL PROVIDE THE
CALIFORNIA CADET CORPS WITH
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO ENHANCE
THE PROGRAM TO ENSURE ALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO APPLIED
LEADERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES THAT
PREPARE STUDENTS FOR SUCCESS IN
COLLEGE AND THE FRAMEWORK AND
THE WORKFORCE. SO, ON BEHALF OF
THE 6000 CADETS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SHOWING SUCCESS AND
PROMISE, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FINAL ITEM 145 THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLLCALL. ANY OBJECTION? SEEING
NONE. AYES 39 O. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEYNE.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. HURTADO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA.
BORG AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
EGGMAN. AYE GROVE. AYE. MIN.
WAHAB AYE. AYES 38. NO. ZERO.
MEASURE. PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 148. SENATOR. SENATOR
DORADO LOOKS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1132 BY SENATOR DURAZZO, AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SB 1132 CLARIFIES THE
AUTHORITY OF COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICERS TO ENTER AND INSPECT
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITIES
OPERATING IN OUR STATE TODAY.
THERE ARE SIX PRIVATE FACILITIES
THAT OPERATE IN A GRAY AREA
UNDER OUR HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODES. AS PUBLIC HEALTH
OVERSIGHT LAWS DO NOT EXPLICITLY
COVER PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES, THESE PRIVATE
FACILITIES ARE OPERATED BY FOR
PROFIT COMPANIES THAT OFTEN FAIL
TO MEET MINIMUM STANDARDS OF
HEALTH, SAFETY, AND SANITATION.
RECENT REPORTS FROM THESE
FACILITIES CONTINUE TO DOCUMENT
A PATTERN OF POOR CONDITIONS,
INADEQUATE HEALTH CARE, AND
UNSAFE WORK CONDITIONS. OUR
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICIALS WILL
ENSURE MINIMUM STANDARDS IN
THESE FACILITIES, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. I
VOTE, ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BORG
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMMER.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. DALLI GROVE. MEN
WHEN AYES 36. NO. ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT ON DECK WE HAVE
FIVE. ITEM 149, 150 AND 152.
SENATOR STERN LOOKS PREPARED FOR
FIRED ON 149. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1471 BY SENATOR
STERN. AN ACT RELATING TO PUPIL
INSTRUCTION. SENATOR. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. SB 1471 BRINGS
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT INTO THE
CLASSROOM BY ALLOWING
AUTHORIZING EDUCATORS TO HAVE A
DAILY MINUTE FOR MINDFULNESS. AT
THE BEGINNING OF EACH SCHOOL
DAY, ONE THIRD OF CALIFORNIA
ADOLESCENTS BETWEEN 12 AND 17
EXPERIENCED PSYCHOLOGICAL
DISTRESS. THERE'S A 70% INCREASE
IN ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION RATES.
WE ALL KNOW THIS THESE
STATISTICS ALL TOO WELL. AND
IT'S NOT JUST STATISTICS, IT'S
REAL LIFE, THIS DAILY MINUTE, AS
WE BOTH WE ALL KNOW HERE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR, GIVES US A MOMENT
TO CENTER OURSELVES. BUT IN THIS
CASE, THIS WOULD JUST BE A, A
MOMENT FOR EITHER SILENCE,
MINDFULNESS, NÓ PRAYER, OR ANY
OF THAT IS REQUIRED, HOPEFULLY
IT GIVES A STUDENTS AN ABILITY
TO FOCUS, SELF-REGULATE AND
RELIEVE TENSION. AND THERE ARE
NUMEROUS NEURODIVERGENT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ALSO MAY BE
SENSITIVE TO SENSORY STIMULI WHO
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS AS WELL?
THIS HAS NO NO VOTES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE, ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? WE GOT ONE. OKAY AYES
39. NO, NO ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM 150 SEN LIMÓN.
ARE YOU PREPARED? SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1195 BY
SENATOR LIMÓN. AN ACT RELATING
TO ASSESSMENTS. THANK YOU. SB
1195 REQUIRES A LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY IN LÀ THAT OPERATES A
BLOCK SCHEDULE TO REQUEST THE
COLLEGE BOARD TO PROVIDE AN
ALTERNATIVE TESTING DATE FOR AP
EXAMS, WHILE MAINTAINING THE
OPTION FOR STUDENTS TO TAKE THE
EXAM IN THE SPRING. SB 1195
ENSURES THAT STUDENTS WHO TAKE
AN AP COURSE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THE EXAM
IMMEDIATELY. FOLLOWING
COMPLETION OF THIS COURSE, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU SENATOR, ANY
DISCUSSION, DEBATE. THIS ITEM IS
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? TO IN A
ROW. THAT'S GREAT. EYES 39 NÓ
ZERO MEASURE PASSES ON TO ITEM
152. SENATOR RUBIO, YOU LOOK
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1295 BY SENATOR
RUBIO. AN ACT RELATING TO
INSURANCE. SENATOR. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1295, A CRITICAL BILL
THAT WILL CLARIFY INSURERS MUST
PROVIDE TEN DAYS NOTICE FOR NON
PAYMENT STARTING AFTER NON
PAYMENT OF A CONSUMER PREMIUM
HAS LAPSED. MANY CONSTITUENTS
ACROSS THE STATE ARE BEING
DROPPED FROM THEIR AUTO INSURER
FOR BEING JUST ONE DAY LATE AND
UNFORTUNATELY IN SOME CASES WE
HAVE HEARD THAT THESE INCIDENTS
ARE DUE TO EITHER BANK ERROR OR
CREDIT CARD ERRORS. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE AND JOINT
AUTHOR FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
COLLABORATING WITH ME ON THIS
BILL THAT WILL ELIMINATE ANY
CONFUSION AND INEQUITIES
CONSUMERS ARE EXPERIENCING WITH
CANCELLATION NOTICES ON THEIR
AUTO INSURANCE POLICIES. THANK
YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CAN WE
GO THREE FOR THREE? THIS ITEM IS
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? AYES 39. NO
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. WE GOT
ONE FINAL ITEM. 155. 159 AND
161. IF YOU WANT TO PREPARE.
THOSE ARE COMING UP NEXT. FILE
ITEM 155. SENATOR WIENER IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 937 BY SENATOR
WIENER AN ACT TO LAND USE,
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SENATOR, I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 937,
TEMPORARILY EXTENDS LAND USE
ENTITLEMENTS FOR HOUSING, GIVEN
THE HIGH INTEREST RATE AND OTHER
CHALLENGING ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE'RE IN, CURRENTLY IN, IN
TERMS OF BUILDING NEW HOUSING.
AND IT ALSO SHIFTS WHEN CERTAIN
IMPACT FEES ARE PAID TO
CERTIFICATE OF OCCUPANCY OR THE
EQUIVALENT AT THE END OF THE
CONSTRUCTION PROCESS. IMPACT
FEES PLAY A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS, WHICH
MANY OF US KNOW AS HAVING SPENT
TIME IN LOCAL ELECTED OFFICE, WE
ALSO KNOW THAT FOR PROJECTS TO
PENCIL AT TIMES HAVING TO PAY
TOO MANY OF THOSE FEES AT THE
VERY BEGINNING, INSTEAD OF THE
AT THE END, CAN HARM THE ABILITY
OF THAT PROJECT TO BE
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE. SO SB 937
WILL ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. WE
WORKED EXTENSIVELY THROUGH THE
PROCESS WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SO THAT ONLY CERTAIN FEES WOULD
BE, PUT TOWARDS THE END OF THE
PROCESS AND THAT FEES THAT ARE
NEEDED FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT CASH
FLOW PURPOSE FOR SPECIFIC NEEDS
WILL STILL BE PAID EARLY ON. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SENATOR DALLI, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. I RISE
ALSO TO IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL,
I SAW THIS IN COMMITTEE. YOU
KNOW, IF YOU'RE IF YOU DON'T GET
THE PROJECT BUILT, NOBODY GETS
THE FEES. SO IF YOU CAN GET THE
PROJECT BUILT, THEN EVENTUALLY
THEY'LL GET THEIR FEES. SO
THAT'S WHY I SUPPORTED THE BILL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR WIENER, YOU MAY CLOSE.
I'M SORRY. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NILO AYE. OCHOA BORG
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN GROVE. AYE. MIN.
WHEN PORTANTINO. AYES 36. NO
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. NOW.
MOVING ON TO ITEM 159. SENATOR
STERN IS PREPARED. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I MEAN,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1301 BY
SENATOR STERN. AN ACT RELATING
TO GAS. SENATOR STERN, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE NATURAL GAS
UTILITIES TO MAKE AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ALL DATA REQUIRED TO DEVELOP
HYDRAULIC MODELS AND HYDRAULIC
FEASIBILITY ANALYZES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE SAFETY AND RELIABILITY
AND TO FACILITATE LONG TERM
PLANNING AND COST EFFECTIVE
EXPENDITURES BY RATEPAYERS. IT
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATORS
WE'RE WAITING TILL TOMORROW AND
WEDNESDAY. ALL RIGHT. THIS ITEM
IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ANY OBJECTION? SEEING
NONE. AYES 39. NO ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES FAR. ITEM 161. SENATOR
ATKINS IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1342 BY
SENATOR ATKINS AND ACT RELATING
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
SENATOR ATKINS, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1342. THIS BILL WITH
WOULD AUTHORIZE CEQA
STREAMLINING FOR TWO KEY CLEAN
ENERGY AND CLEAN WATER PROJECTS
IN THE SAN DIEGO REGION THE SAN
DIEGO, SAN VICENTE PUMP STORAGE
PROJECT IN EASTERN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND THE SOUTH BAY
INTERNATIONAL WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANT, WHICH, AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW, IS NEAR THE MEXICO
CALIFORNIA BORDER. THIS IS THE
SAME CEQA STREAMLINING THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
APPROVED LAST SUMMER IN SB 149
FOR OTHER ENERGY, WATER AND
MICROCHIP INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. THAT STREAMLINING WAS
SUPPORTED BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM,
BUSINESS, ENERGY AND MAJOR
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS. THE SAN
VICENTE PUMP STORAGE PROJECT IS
URGENTLY NEEDED FOR CLEAN ENERGY
AND LOAD SUPPORT IN THE SAN
DIEGO REGION TO SAVE RATEPAYERS
MILLIONS IN ENERGY COSTS. THE
PROJECT DEVELOPER IS CURRENTLY
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE SAN
DIEGO WATER AUTHORITY TO BUILD
THE PROJECT. WE'RE CERTAINLY ALL
FAMILIAR WITH THE CROSS-BORDER
SEWAGE CRISIS THAT'S CLOSED
BEACHES AND PUBLIC SPACES AND
IMPACTING THE AIR QUALITY FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. THIS IS DUE
TO YEARS OF DELAY AND THE
ONGOING DISCHARGE OF RAW SEWAGE
FROM THE SOUTH BAY. TREATMENT
PLANT. THE PLANT IS IN DESPERATE
NEED OF UPGRADE AND POSSIBLE
RECONSTRUCTION, EXTENDING CEQA,
STREAMLINING TO THESE PROJECTS
IS ENTIRELY ELECTIVE AND AT THE
OPTION OF THE PROJECT APPLICANT.
THIS WILL SHAVE MONTHS OR YEARS
OFF COMPLETING THESE PROJECTS.
THIS IS SUPPORTED BY THE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES, CARPENTERS, IRON WORKERS
, OPERATING ENGINEERS, TEAMSTERS
AND THE SAN DIEGO CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, AS WELL AS OTHERS.
IT'S COAUTHORED BY THE
BIPARTISAN SAN DIEGO DELEGATION
AND IS SPONSORED BY THE SAN
DIEGO WATER AUTHORITY. I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT, SEN. PADILLA.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED BRIEFLY. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT, FOR THE
REASONS ARTICULATED BY THE
AUTHOR AND AS A COAUTHOR, I RISE
IN SUPPORT ANY OTHER FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
ATKINS, YOU MAY CLOSE. GOOD ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLLCALL. ANY OBJECTION? WE'RE
DOING GREAT. AYES 39. NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. ALL RIGHT. THE
NEXT THREE UP TO BAT IS FILE
ITEM 166 168 AND 170. WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH 166. SENATOR
UMBERG IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 918 BY
SENATOR UMBERG. AN ACT RELATING
TO SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
SENATOR UMBERG, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. SB 918,
THE SOCIAL MEDIA AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT COOPERATION ACT
WOULD REQUIRE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO HAVE A TELEPHONE
HOTLINE AVAILABLE AT TIMES FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE A TIMELY REQUEST
FOR INFORMATION ALSO COMPELS
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS TO
IMMEDIATELY COMPLY WITH THE
SEARCH WARRANT PROVIDED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. IF THE
SUBJECT OF THE SEARCH WARRANT THAT SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM, I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE
ANOTHER ITEM ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? SEEING NONE. AYES 39.
NØ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM ONE 6068. SENATOR RUBIO,
ARE YOU PREPARED? SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1106 BY
SENATOR RUBIO, AN ACT RELATING
TO CONSERVATORSHIP. SENATOR
RUBIO, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, TODAY, I PROUDLY,
PROUDLY RISE TO PRESENT SB 1106
NAMED CASEY KASEM NICHOLAS
ROONEY LAW, WHICH AIMS TO
STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS FOR OLDER
ADULTS UNDER CONSERVATORSHIP
FROM BEING ISOLATED BY THEIR
CARETAKERS. THIS BILL REQUIRES
LOVED ONES TO BE NOTIFIED IF
THERE IS A CHANGE IN CURRENT
RESIDENCE, IF THE CONSERVATOR
PASSED AWAY AND DETAILS OF THE
MEMORIAL SERVICES. UNFORTUNATELY
THERE HAVE BEEN COUNTLESS
INSTANCES OF ELDER ABUSE UNDER
CONSERVATORSHIPS THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED IF CLOSE FAMILY
MEMBERS AND FRIENDS KNEW THE
WHEREABOUTS OF THEIR LOVED ONES.
CALIFORNIA'S ELDERLY POPULATION
IS GROWING SUBSTANTIALLY. THE
NUMBER OF OLDER PEOPLE, THOSE
OVER 65, WILL DOUBLE OVER THE
NEXT 20 YEARS, FROM
APPROXIMATELY 4 MILLION TO OVER
8 MILLION. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
BE PROACTIVE IN STRENGTHENING
THE LAWS THAT PROTECT THESE
OLDER POPULATION FROM FACING
ABUSE AND NEGLECT, AND ARE
UNABLE TO ESCAPE THEIR ABUSERS.
THIS BILL IS CRITICAL, AND IT'S
A FIRST STEP IN PUTTING POLICIES
IN PLACE THAT WILL HELP PREVENT
ISOLATION AND MISTREATMENT OF A
LOVED ONE UNDER CONSERVATORSHIP.
THIS BILL HAS STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION. WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM 168? WE HAVE ANOTHER WINNER
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL.
ANY OBJECTION? NO, THAT'S AYES
39. NO, ZERO. WITH THAT,
COLLEAGUES, WE ARE ONE HOUR IN
AND WE'VE DONE 19 BILLS OUT OF
THE 300 AND SOMETHING THIS WEEK
ON A GOOD ROLL, NEXT UP FOR ITEM
170. SENATOR STERN, ARE YOU
PREPARED? SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 13, A SENATE BILL
1399 BY SENATOR STERN AND ACT
RELATING TO PROPERTY. SENATOR
STERN, GO AHEAD. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS SB 1399
WOULD CLARIFY IN STATUTE THAT
THE RECORDATION OF PRIVATE
TRANSFER FEE COVENANTS ARE
PERMITTED FOR PROPERTIES THAT
HAD SUCH AN AGREEMENT IN PLACE
PRIOR TO 2019 TO AVOID ANY
CONFUSION ON THIS CLARIFICATION,
WOULD ENSURE PREEXISTING
AGREEMENTS, INCLUDING THOSE THAT
SUPPORT ONGOING CONSERVATION AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS,
ARE IMPLEMENTED AS ENVISIONED.
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION. BROAD
ENVIRONMENTAL SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
FINAL ITEM 170. SEEING NONE, WE
ARE GOING BACK TO ROLL CALL.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. DODD AYE. DURAZO. EGGMAN.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE MIN.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO
AYE. OCHOA. B¢O. AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
AYE. DALLI AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. MIN. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. AYES 39. NO. ZERO.
MEASURE. PASSES. NEXT. THREE ARE
FILE ITEM ONE, 75, 177 AND 187.
SENATOR NEIL, ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR ITEM 175? SECOND SECRETARY,
PLEASE. FILE SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1141 BY SENATOR
NILO AND ACT RELATING TO CIVIL
ACTIONS. THANK YOU AGAIN, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT TO
YOU SB 1141, WHICH INCREASES THE
THRESHOLD OF CASES THAT CAN BE
SENT TO MANDATORY MEDIATION BY
THE COURTS FROM THE CURRENT
50,000 TO 150,000. THE CURRENT
THRESHOLD OF 50,000 WAS SET OVER
30 YEARS AGO. SB 1141 RAISES
THAT THRESHOLD TO, AS I STATED,
150,000. CALIFORNIA'S COURTS ARE
CONGESTED EACH YEAR OF THE LAST
THREE YEARS. THE NUMBER OF
UNLIMITED CIVIL CASE FILINGS
WERE MORE THAN DOUBLE THE NUMBER
OF CASE DISPOSITIONS THE
HURRIED. HERE WE GO, THE
BEHINDER WE GET, BUT WE HAVE A
SOLUTION. EARLY RESOLUTION WHEN
POSSIBLE, IS BENEFICIAL FOR
REDUCING THE COSTS AND BURDEN OF
ALL PARTIES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? WELL, WE HAVE ANOTHER
ITEM ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. OKAY. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE RAY.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MINH NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. OKUBO
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MCGUIRE AYE. MIN. WAHAB
AYES 38. NO. ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO ITEM 177.
SENATOR BRADFORD, ARE YOU
PREPARED? SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1020 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD AND ACT RELATING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY REGULATIONS.
SENATOR BRADFORD THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. SB 1020 WOULD
PROHIBIT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES FROM UTILIZING SHOOTING
TARGETS THAT RESEMBLE ETHNIC
GROUPS AND THE MULTITUDE OF
STUDIES PUBLISHED BY THE
AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION RESEARCH RESEARCHERS
ESTABLISHED THAT PARTICIPANTS
WOULD SHOOT AN ARMED TARGET
QUICKER IF IT RESEMBLED AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN, COMPARED TO IF
THEY WERE WHITE. PARTICIPANTS
WERE ALSO LIKELY TO SHOOT AN
UNARMED, I SHOULD SAY, LESS
LIKELY TO SHOOT AN UNARMED WHITE
TARGET COMPARED TO AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN ONE JUST THREE
WEEKS AGO. COLLEAGUES, WE SADLY
SAW WHAT HAPPENED TO AIRMAN
ROGER FORTSON, WHO OPENED THE
DOOR WITHIN THREE SECONDS IN
FLORIDA. HE WAS GUNNED DOWN,
SHOT FIVE TIMES BY BY A POLICE
OFFICER. MR. FORTSON HAPPENED TO
BE AFRICAN AMERICAN. I CHALLENGE
YOU TO SAY IF THAT WOULD HAVE
RULES WOULD HAVE BEEN REVERSED
AND I WOULD HAVE BEEN A
CAUCASIAN PERSON. THAT PERSON
WOULD MORE THAN LIKELY WOULD
STILL BE ALIVE TODAY. THESE
RESPONSE TIMES SHOW SUBCONSCIOUS
RACIAL BIAS, WHICH LEADS TOWARDS
AN INCREASED RISK OF DEADLY HARM
TOWARDS CERTAIN ETHNIC GROUPS.
SB 1020 IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE THAT WILL ENSURE
IMPLICIT RACIAL BIASES ARE NOT
PRESENT IN OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS, AND THAT ALL PEOPLE
ARE TREATED EQUAL AND FAIRLY. I
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM 177? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GIL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI DODD. DALLI. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. BORG.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBER AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO GIL. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. MIN WHEN NILO.
OCHOA. BORG. SATO AYES 33. NO
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 182. SENATOR
HURTADO LOOKS READY. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1448 BY
SENATOR HURTADO. AN ACT RELATING
TO FOOD AND AGRICULTURE. PLEASE
PROCEED. SENATOR. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1448, A BILL THAT
WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO LAND AND
MARKETS FOR SMALL AND
UNDERSERVED FARMERS. ACCESS TO
LAND IS A SIGNIFICANT HURDLE FOR
SMALL, UNDERSERVED AND LIMITED
RESOURCES. FARMERS LAND ACCESS
IS MULTIFACETED AND COMPLEX,
WITH A COMBINATION OF HISTORICAL
DISCRIMINATION AND THEFT. PAIRED
WITH TODAY'S INCREASING PRESSURE
OF HEDGE FUNDS AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENT COMPANIES, RAPIDLY
PURCHASING AG LAND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, LOCAL AND REGIONAL
FOOD SUPPLY CHAINS HAVE BEEN
DRASTICALLY UNDERFUNDED AND
UNDER RESOURCED, LEAVING SMALL
FAMILY FARMERS TO DEVELOP NEW
SUPPLY CHAINS WITH LITTLE TO NO
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO INVEST IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY FOR
SUSTAINABLE TRANSFORMATION. SB
1448 ADDRESSES ESSENTIAL EQUITY
ISSUES FOR TWO IMPORTANT
EXISTING PROGRAMS. IT WOULD
CLARIFY THE TASK FORCE MEMBERS
MAY RECEIVE A REASONABLE PER
DIEM USING EXISTING OR PRIVATE
FUNDS, SIMILAR TO OTHER TASK
FORCE AND COMMITTEES. COMMITTEES
USE IT WILL ENSURE THE AG LAND
EQUITY TASK FORCE REPORT IS MADE
PUBLIC AND IT STREAMLINES THE
FARM TO COMMUNITY FOOD HUB
PROGRAM ADVISORY COMMITTEE BY
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, BEING LESS PRESCRIPTIVE
AND ALLOWING FOR MEMBERS OF
EXISTING CDFA COMMITTEES TO
SERVE AND EXTEND THE SUNSET FOR
THE FARM TO COMMUNITY FOOD HUB
PROGRAM. TO ENSURE IT HAS
SUFFICIENT TIME TO COMPLY WITH
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SENATORS, IT'S GETTING A
LITTLE LOUD OUT HERE. IF WE HAVE
ANY CONVERSATIONS, IF WE COULD
PLEASE TAKE THEM OFF THE FLOOR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OR ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
FINAL ITEM. 182. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. AYE. OCHOA.
BOGH AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEN. WHEN? AYE AYES 39. NO.
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. NEXT THREE
ON DECK. WE HAVE FILE ITEM 187,
192 AND 198. SENATOR UMBERG, ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR FILE ITEM 187?
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 900 BY SENATOR UMBERG ENACT
RELATING TO COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS. SENATOR. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL IS A RESULT
OF AN EVENT THAT HAPPENED IN
ORANGE COUNTY, WHERE NEARLY 600
HOMEOWNERS AND TENANTS WERE LEFT
WITHOUT GAS FOR OVER THREE
MONTHS, GAS TO COOK WITH, GAS
FOR HOT WATER. GAS FOR ALL
PURPOSES FOR WHICH GAS IS USED
FOR. AND THE CHALLENGE WAS, IS
ONCE THIS GAS LINE WAS
INTERRUPTED, AS THERE WAS A
SERIES OF FINGER POINTING AS TO
WHO HAD RESPONSIBILITY TO REMEDY
THE SITUATION, THIS IS AN
OCCURRENCE THAT I THOUGHT ONLY
HAPPENED IN ORANGE COUNTY, BUT
APPARENTLY IT IS MUCH MORE
WIDESPREAD. SO, FOR EXAMPLE,
LAST MONTH, 174 RESIDENTS AT A
MOBILE HOME PARK IN VACAVILLE
WERE IN THE SAME SITUATION.
JANUARY 2023, 162 UNITS AT A
CONDOMINIUM COMPLEX IN
SACRAMENTO. IN THE SAME
SITUATION, THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS
THAT THE HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
BOARD, ONCE THEY'RE NOTIFIED OF
THIS LEAK, HAS TEN DAYS BY WHICH
TO START REPAIRS. FOR THESE
CRITICAL INTERRUPTIONS ALLOWS
THE MANAGEMENT COMPANY TO ACT.
IT ALLOWS THE MANAGEMENT
COMPANIES TO ACT SWIFTLY TO FIX
THE UTILITIES. IF THE BOARD
DOESN'T MEET AND REQUIRES
REPAIRS TO HAVE FAIR PRICING
INSTITUTES RESERVE STUDIES TO
ENSURE ORGANIZED AND TRANSPARENT
BUDGETING PROCESSES, AND ALLOWS
THE HOA'S TO CONDUCT ELECTRONIC
VOTING TO ACHIEVE A QUORUM, I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, AND DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ITEM 187. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI. AYE. DODD.
AYE DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON. AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN
AYE. WHEN I. NILO AYE. OCHOA.
BORG AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. HURTADO
AYE. MEN. PADILLA AYE. AYES 39.
NØ. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 192. SENATOR
LIMON, ARE YOU PREPARED? THE
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1369 BY SENATOR LIMÓN. AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. SENATOR LIMON, THANK
YOU. DENTAL PLANS. CONTRACT WITH
THIRD PARTY COMPANIES TO ISSUE
PROVIDER PAYMENTS TO DENTAL
PRACTICES WITH VIRTUAL CREDIT
CARDS. ACCEPTING THIS FORM OF
PAYMENT, HOWEVER, CHARGES THE
DENTAL OFFICE PROCESSING,
PROCESSING FEES 2 TO 5% OF THE
TOTAL PAYMENT AMOUNT. IN
ADDITION TO THE STANDARD
MERCHANT TRANSACTION FEE FOR
PROCESSING THE PAYMENT THROUGH
THEIR CREDIT CARD TERMINAL. SB
1369 REQUIRES DENTAL PLANS AND
CONTRACTED VIRTUAL CREDIT CARD
COMPANIES TO PROVIDE NOTICE OF
ANY FEES ASSOCIATED WITH PAYMENT
FOR DENTAL SERVICES, AND GIVES
PROVIDERS THE ABILITY TO OPT IN
TO VIRTUAL TO RECEIVE VIRTUAL
CREDIT CARDS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON FILE ITEM
192 SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. AYE AYE. OCHOA.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. TALLY MCGUIRE.
AYE. MIN WHEN AYE OR TROUBLE.
AYES 37. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES
. FILE ITEM 198. SENATOR LAIRD
LOOKS PREPARED. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1097 BY
SENATOR LAIRD AND AQUILINO TO
VETERANS. SENATOR LAIRD, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATE BILL 1097 WILL UPDATE THE
MILITARY AND VETERANS CODE TO
USE GENDER INCLUSIVE LANGUAGE,
CLARIFY THAT BENEFITS AND
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED BY
SURVIVING SPOUSES ARE ALSO
AVAILABLE TO DOMESTIC PARTNERS,
AND WILL CLOSE A MINOR LOOPHOLE
TO CLARIFY ONLY SERVICE MEMBERS
ON ACTIVE MILITARY DUTY ORDERS
SHALL BE EXEMPT FROM JURY DUTY.
I DID A SIMILAR BILL TWO YEARS
AGO, SB 272 FOR THE COMMISSIONER
OF THE HIGHWAY PATROL, AMANDA
RAY. SHE WAS APPOINTED THE FIRST
WOMAN TO BE THE COMMISSIONER OF
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
AND YET THE ENTIRE CODE REFERRED
TO THE COMMISSIONER AS HE. SO
THIS BILL DOES THE SAME FOR THE
MILITARY AND VETERANS CODE. THE
BILL HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AND HAS HAD NO NO
VOTES. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
OCHOA. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLI GROVE. JONES.
MIN. WHEN NILO. OKUBO. SAWYER.
AYES 32. NO. ZERO MEASURE PASSES
NEXT THREE ON DECK IS FILE ITEM
ONE, 99, 201 AND 204. SENATOR
ASHBY IS PREPARED WITH FILE ITEM
199. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1110 BY SENATOR
ASHBY. AN ACT RELATING TO WATER.
SENATOR ASHBY, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1110 THE WATER EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS ACT. BILL ADDS TWO
YEAR EXTENSION TO NGUYEN. THE
BOARD MAY ISSUE INFORMATIONAL
ORDERS RELATED TO WATER
PRODUCTION, WATER USE, WATER
CONSERVATION, OR URBAN RETAIL
WATER SUPPLIER THAT IS NOT
MEETING ITS URBAN WATER USE
OBJECTIVES. THIS ALLOWS THE
WATER BOARD TIME TO ESTABLISH
ITS RULEMAKING BEFORE CONDUCTING
COMPLIANCE ENFORCEMENT, AS
AMENDED, SB 1110 HAS NO
OPPOSITION. URGENT. I VOTE
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL.
ANY OBJECTION? SEEING NONE. AYES
39 NØ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM 201. SENATOR LARRY IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
. SENATE BILL 1190 BY SENATOR
LAIRD. AN ACT RELATING TO MOBILE
HOMES. SENATOR LAIRD, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, IF YOU LIVE IN AN
INDIVIDUAL MOBILE HOME AND THERE
AND YOU WISH TO UPGRADE THE TO
SOLAR AND THE COVENANTS OR PARK
WIDE, DON'T ALLOW YOU TO DO IT,
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW INDIVIDUAL
MOBILE HOME OWNERS TO UPGRADE TO
A SOLAR. WE ENGAGED WITH THE
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION
ADDRESSED THEIR CONCERNS. THEY
ARE NEUTRAL, THEIR SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES AND HAS HAD NO NO
VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? FANTASTIC
EYES 39. NO ZERO. FILE ITEM 201.
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
ITEM TWO A4. SENATOR LEHMAN IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1266 BY SENATOR
LEHMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
PRODUCT SAFETY. SENATOR LEHMAN,
THANK YOU. SB 1266 SEEKS TO
PROHIBIT MANUFACTURERS FROM
SELLING JUVENILE FEEDING,
SUCKING OR TEETHING PRODUCTS
THAT CONTAIN ANY FORM OF
BISPHENOLS OR BP'S AT A
DETECTABLE LEVEL OF 0.1 PARTS
PER BILLION. SB 1266 STRENGTHENS
THE COMMITMENT TO PROTECT
CHILDREN FROM HARMFUL CHEMICALS,
AND AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL TO
ESTABLISH STANDARDS PRIORITIZING
THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS OF OUR
CHILDREN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS. DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? FILE ITEM 204. THIS
HAS. THIS IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 39. NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT THREE. WE
GOT ITEM 207 209 AND 214.
SENATOR WAHAB LOOKS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1317 BY SENATOR WAHAB. AN
ACT RELATING TO COUNTY JAIL
INMATES. SARAH WAHAB, THANK YOU.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1317 COURT
ORDERED MEDS FOR COUNTY JAILS.
SB 1317 EXTENDS FOR FIVE YEARS
THE SUNSET DATE FOR SEEKING
COURT ORDERS TO ADMINISTER
INVOLUNTARY PSYCHIATRIC
MEDICATION TO THOSE WITH SEVERE
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS WHO ARE
DETAINED IN COUNTY JAILS EXIST.
EXISTING LAW AUTHORIZES
PSYCHIATRY IN COUNTY JAILS TO
OBTAIN AN INVOLUNTARY MEDICATION
ORDER FOR PERSONS IN CUSTODY WHO
ARE A DANGER TO THEMSELVES AND
OR OTHERS, OR ARE SUFFERING FROM
GRAVE DISABILITIES AND UNABLE TO
GIVE CONSENT. SB 1317 ALSO WOULD
REQUIRE COUNTIES THAT ELECT TO
USE THIS AUTHORITY TO SUBMIT
SPECIFIED REPORTING INFORMATION.
MAINTAINING THIS AUTHORITY IS
ADDRESSES THE NEEDS OF THOSE IN
COUNTY JAILS WITH THE MOST
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
NEEDS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE ANY DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
WE ARE ON A ROLL WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. THIS ITEM IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? AYES 30.
ANY OBJECTION ON UTEO. THE
UNANIMOUS AYES 39. NØ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES FOR ITEM 209.
SENATOR WAHAB IS PREPARED AGAIN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1356 BY SENATOR WAHAB. AN
ACT RELATING TO THE JUDICIARY.
SENATOR WAHAB. THANK YOU. I RISE
TO PRESENT SB 1356 GENDER
PERSPECTIVE. JUDGING THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE TRAININGS OFFERED
BY JUDICIAL COUNCIL. CONSIDER
THE ROLE OF GENDER IN COURT
PROCEEDINGS, INCLUDING
STRATEGIES TO COUNTER
STEREOTYPES AND TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT INEQUITIES IN POWER AND
THEIR INTERSECTION WITH GENDER,
AND MEET THE NEEDS OF LITIGANTS
IN UNIQUE SITUATIONS OF
VULNERABILITY. SB 1356 BUILDS
UPON EXISTING LAW TO ENSURE WE
CONTINUE TO ELIMINATE
DISCRIMINATION AND BIAS IN OUR
JUDICIAL SYSTEM. THIS IS
SYSTEMIC CHANGE. ANY DISCUSSION
ON FILE ITEM 209. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEMON.
AYE MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M
IN. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NHIÀU
OCHOA. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLI. EGGMAN AYE.
GROVE JONES. MIN. NGUYEN NILO.
OCHOA. BOGUE CIERTO. AYES 32.
NÓ. ZERO. MEASURE. PASSES FILE
ITEM 214 SEN. LETTERS. SENATOR.
LAIRD IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1440 BY
SENATOR LAIRD. AN ACT RELATING
TO WATER QUALITY. SENATOR LAIRD,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATE BILL 1440 INCREASES
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT FOR THE
WATER BOARD BY REQUIRING THE
BOARD TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING STORMWATER
PERMITTING COMPLIANCE. RECENT
DATA HAS SHOWN A DECLINE IN
ANNUAL COMPLIANCE, AND THIS WILL
ENSURE THE LEGISLATURE HAS AN
ACTIVE ROLE IN THE PROTECTION OF
WATER QUALITY. THE BILL HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION, HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT, AND
HAS A SUPPORT SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION FARNHAM
TO 14 ITEM IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 39. NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT THREE WE
HAVE IS FILE ITEM 216 217 AND
223. SENATOR JERAS, ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR FILE ITEM 216?
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1488 BY SENATOR DURAZZO, AN
ACT RELATING TO OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING. SENATOR DURAZZO.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. SB
1488 DIRECTS CALTRANS TO SUPPORT
ARENA ADVERTISING DISPLAYS IN
THEIR CURRENT NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE FEDERAL HIGHWAY
ADMINISTRATION. THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO REDUCE THE LENGTH OF TIME
FOR A MARKETING CONTRACT FROM
ONE YEAR TO 120 DAYS, WHICH MORE
ACCURATELY, ACCURATELY REFLECTS
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING
OPPORTUNITIES. IT PROVIDES
STADIUMS AND ARENAS REVENUE
STREAMS THAT DO NOT RELY ON
PUBLIC FUNDING. STADIUMS CREATE
THOUSANDS OF PERMANENT LOCAL
GOOD CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND
PERMANENT JOBS GENERATE MILLIONS
IN TAXES. THESE MESSAGE BOARDS
ALSO PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN
HELPING DIRECT TRAFFIC AROUND
THE STADIUM AND PUBLIC SAFETY
ALERTS. THE UPDATED MARKETING
AGREEMENTS REFLECTS THE EVER
CHANGING MODELS OF ADVERTISING,
AND ENABLE STADIUMS TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT,
JOBS AND ECONOMIC IMPACT WITH
LOS ANGELES. IN MY CASE, HOSTING
THE OLYMPICS AND WORLD CUP, OUR
STADIUM AND ARENA INFRASTRUCTURE
WILL NEED UPDATING, BRINGING
MARKETING AGREEMENTS CLOSER TO
THE STANDARDS OF THE INDUSTRY
WILL KEEP STADIUMS MODERNIZED
AND READY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THESE WORLD EVENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
SEN. JONES YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I'M GOING TO VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL, BUT I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD BE TAKING A SERIOUS LOOK
AT REFORMING THIS ENTIRE SYSTEM
AND COME BACK WITH A MORE ROBUST
REFORMS ON THIS. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION, SENATOR
DEROSA, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU. I JUST WANT TO REMIND MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THE MARKETING
PLAN PROVISIONS ARE WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S PURVIEW.
SO WE ARE NOT INCLUDING ANYTHING
THAT FALLS UNDER THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S PURVIEW. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. DALLI
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE LIMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO. NO.
OCHOA. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER.
AYE WILK. NO. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLI.
NO EGGMAN. AYE. CORTEZ AYE. MEN.
WHEN NO. AYES 31. NOS. A MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO ITEM 217.
THE SENATOR IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1175 BY SENATOR OCHOA AND
ACRYLATES. ORGANIC WASTE.
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN REACHING
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS, SB
1175 WILL REQUIRE CALRECYCLE TO
CONSIDER ALTERNATIVES IN
ADDITION TO CENSUS TRACKS. WHEN
DECIDING THE BOUNDARIES OF A
JURISDICTION ELIGIBLE FOR A
WAIVER OF SOME OR ALL OF THE
COLLECTION REQUIREMENTS OF SB
1383, THESE ALTERNATIVES INCLUDE
ESTABLISHED BOUNDARIES OF CITIES
AND CENSUS DESIGNATED PLACES, AS
WELL AS BOUNDARY MAP MAPS
SUBMITTED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHO DEVELOP WASTE MANAGEMENT
ROUTES. SB 1175 PASSED THE
SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY.
AMENDMENTS TO DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL THE NEXT
UPDATE TO SB 1383 REGULATIONS
HAVE ADDRESSED ALL REMAINING
CONCERNS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR GROVE,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I TOO, RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1175 WHEN, SB 1383
BY SENATOR LARA PASSED IN 2016,
IT REQUIRED CAL CAL RECYCLED TO
IMPLEMENT ORGANIC WASTE. PLANNED
DISPOSAL OR DISPOSAL PLANS
COMPLY WITH THE PROPOSAL. OFTEN
CONSISTS COUNTIES OF IMPOSING
NEW PROPERTY OWNERS AS HIGH TAX
FEES AS $600 A YEAR. SINCE SB
1383 PASSED, SEVERAL BILLS HAVE
TRIED TO CREATE EXEMPTIONS FOR
POLICY FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE STRUGGLED TO COMPLY
WITH THE ORIGINAL BILL FROM
SENATOR LARA, I MYSELF
INTRODUCED SB 1232 THIS YEAR,
WHICH HAVE CREATED AN EXEMPTION
FOR PROP 18 FOR THOSE THAT WERE
SEXUALLY PROTESTED IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES TO NOT HAVE TO
SUSTAIN THE HIGH COST OF THE FEE
OF ALMOST $600. AND FORTUNATELY,
IT FAILED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT I'M REALLY HAPPY THAT SB
1175 HAS MADE IT TO THE CENTER.
THE SENATE FLOOR REQUIRING CAL
RECYCLED TO CONSIDER
ALTERNATIVES TO THE CENSUS
TRACKS WHEN REVIEWING LOW
POPULATION AND ELEVATION WAIVERS
FROM THE STATE'S ORGANIC WASTE
REQUIREMENT, IS IMPORTANT TO OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES. MEMBERS, A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE SENIORS. THE
POPULATION AREAS ABOVE 65 YEARS
OLD, AND THEY'RE ON A FIXED
INCOME TO IMPOSE THIS ON LOWLY
LOW LEVEL POPULATED AREAS WHERE
MOSTLY OUR SENIORS ARE LIVING IS
JUST NOT A GOOD THING. AND THERE
NEEDS TO BE AN OFF RAMP FOR
THESE PEOPLE WHO REALLY, TRULY
CAN'T AFFORD THESE PLANS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. YES. THANK YOU. I
WANTED TO RISE AND EXPRESS THAT
I WILL BE VOTING NO ON THIS. AND
THE REASON IS THAT IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION, THERE ARE
CURRENTLY TEN BILLS, INCLUDING
THIS BILL, THAT SEEK TO AMEND,
STREAMLINE OR EXTEND VARIOUS
REQUIREMENTS OF CAL RECYCLES
REGULATIONS FOR SB 1383. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT THE SB
1383 BILLS ALL IN THE UNIVERSE
AND NOT IN ISOLATION AND
FUNDAMENTALLY, I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE STICK TO THE
AMBITIOUS PRINCIPLES OF SB 1383,
I DO NOT AGREE WITH THE PREMISE
OF EXEMPTING MORE JURISDICTIONS
FROM SB 1383. 151 JURISDICTIONS
ARE ALREADY EXEMPTED FROM SB
1383, AND LAST YEAR IT WAS ONLY
54 JURISDICTIONS. SO WE ARE
EXPANDING THE REACH OF THOSE
AREAS THAT ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE REALLY
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS OF SB
1383. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION, SENATOR, YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, IN ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED, I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT CURRENT
REGULATIONS ALLOW FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO APPLY FOR WAIVERS
FOR SOME OR ALL OF SB 1383
COLLECTION REQUIREMENTS FOR
AREAS THAT ARE HIGH ELEVATION
AND SPARSELY POPULATED AND OR
RURAL. HOWEVER, THESE WAIVERS
ARE NOT BASED ON WELL
ESTABLISHED BOUNDARIES LIKE CITY
OR COUNTY LINES, BUT ON CENSUS
TRACTS, CENSUS TRACTS WHICH ARE
GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS CURRENTLY
USED ONLY FOR CENSUS PURPOSES,
AND THE RESULT IS THAT THE THESE
BOUNDARIES ARE OF AREAS ELIGIBLE
FOR A WAIVER MAKE LITTLE SENSE
FOR THE PURPOSES OF DISPOSING
ORGANIC WASTE. FOR EXAMPLE, IN
MY DISTRICT, RUNNING SPRINGS IS
AN UNINCORPORATED TOWN IN SAN
BERNARDINO MOUNTAINS. IT'S SPLIT
BETWEEN TWO CENSUS TRACTS, ONE
WITH LOW POPULATION WAIVER AND
ONE WITH AN ELEVATION WAIVER.
THIS MEANS THAT NEIGHBORS
LITERALLY LIVING ACROSS THE
STREET FROM EACH OTHER HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH DIFFERENT COLLECTION
REQUIREMENTS, WHICH ALSO IMPOSES
DIFFERENT FEES. THIS ALSO POSES
LOGICAL CHALLENGES FOR WASTE
MANAGEMENT ENTITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKESPEAR.
NO. BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DELI AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE.
AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OCHOA. BOG AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER MEN.
STERN AYES 36 ONE. NO MEASURE
PASSES FIVE. ITEM 223. SENATOR
EGGMAN IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1051 BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO TENANCIES. SENATOR EGGMAN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MEMBERS.
THIS BILL WILL STANDARDIZE
EXISTING TENANT PROTECTIONS BY
UPDATING LAWS TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CAN GET THEIR
LOCKS CHANGED, AND NOT BE
PENALIZED. FOR THAT. I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM? SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NILO AYE. OCHOA
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLI AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GROVE. AYE. JONES
AYE. MIN. WHEN SATO. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WILK AYE. WHEN I.
AYES 38. NO. ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT THREE YEARS. FILE
ITEM 228, 231 AND 233. SENATOR
WIENER LOOKS PREPARED. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM 228.
SENATE BILL 966 BY SENATOR
WIENER. AN ACT RELATING TO
PHARMACY BENEFITS. SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I'M PRESENTING
SENATE BILL 966, WHICH WILL
REQUIRE PHARMACY BENEFIT
MANAGERS OR PBMS TO BE LICENSED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
AND ALSO TO CREATE CERTAIN LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS AROUND
TRANSPARENCY, ACCOUNTABILITY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. PBMS ARE
INTERMEDIARIES BETWEEN HEALTH
INSURERS OR AMONG HEALTH
INSURERS, PHARMACIES AND
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES. THE
ROLE OF PBMS, WHICH PERFORM
SERVICES LIKE CREATING
FORMULARIES, NEGOTIATING DRUG
PRICING AND THEIR ROLE HAS GROWN
FROM PROCESSING CLAIMS TO A
MUCH, MUCH BROADER ARRAY OF
SERVICES. THEY'VE ALSO GROWN
DRAMATICALLY IN SIZE AND PLAY A
VERY, VERY PROMINENT ROLE IN THE
HEALTH CARE SPACE. AND YET IN
CALIFORNIA, THEY DON'T HAVE TO
BE LICENSED. AND THERE ARE FEW,
IF ANY RULES GOVERNING THEIR
BEHAVIOR, THERE ARE OVER 60 PBMS
IN THE US, BUT A HUGE MAJORITY
OF PRESCRIPTION DRUG CLAIMS ARE
PROCESSED BY A MERE THREE PBMS,
25 OTHER STATES ALREADY REQUIRE
PBMS TO BE LICENSED, AND VARIOUS
STATES REQUIRE ASPECTS OF THE
REGULATIONS THAT SB 966 CREATES.
COLLEAGUES, IT'S TIME TO START
REGULATING PBMS, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. ANY DISCUSSION OF ITEM 228
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MEN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE. Ó. AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. DALLI. AYE HURTADO. AYE.
MEN AYE. AYES 39. NO. ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. GOING BACK TO
SENATOR WIENER. HE'S PREPARED
FOR FINAL ITEM. 231 SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 988 BY
SENATOR WIENER. AN ACT RELATING
TO INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS.
SENATOR WIENER, I THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES SB
988 IS THE FREELANCE WORKER
PROTECTION ACT, WHICH PROVIDES
VERY BASIC PROTECTIONS FOR
FREELANCE WORKERS. IT'S ACTUALLY
SHOCKING THAT THIS IS NOT
ALREADY THE LAW, MOST
FREELANCERS LACK EVEN THE MOST
BASIC OF WORKER PROTECTIONS
ÓRDENES MOST NOTABLY, THE RIGHT
TO BE PAID ON TIME FOR THEIR
WORK. ACCORDING TO THE
FREELANCERS UNION, 71% OF
FREELANCE WORKERS EXPERIENCE A
LATE OR NONPAYMENT, 59% REPORT
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK, AND
ONLY 25% REPORT THAT THEY
CONSISTENTLY HAVE WRITTEN
CONTRACTS FOR THEIR WORK. IN
2020, THREE SIMILAR VERSIONS OF
THIS BILL WERE ENACTED IN BOTH
ILLINOIS AND NEW YORK, AND IN
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR, LA COUNTY
ADOPTED SIMILAR LEGISLATION.
IT'S TIME TO TAKE IT STATEWIDE.
THE BILL WILL REQUIRE WRITTEN
CONTRACTS, 30 DAY PAYMENT TERMS
UNLESS THE CONTRACT PROVIDES FOR
A DIFFERENT PAYMENT SCHEDULE,
PAYMENT AGREEMENT PROTECTIONS
ANTI-RETALIATION MEASURES AND
DAMAGES PROTECTIONS, MAKING SURE
THAT THESE WORKERS ACTUALLY GET
PAID. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR,
AND DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM 231.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLI DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. BORG AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO.
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD AYE. DALLI
GROVE. MIN NGUYEN. NO. NILO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. AYES 33.
NO THREE MEASURE PASSES FOR ITEM
233. SENATOR PADILLA, YOU'RE
PREPARED. SECONDER. PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 990 BY SENATOR
PADILLA AND AQUILINO TO STATE
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
990 IS AN ASTRAL DISASTERS
BECOME A MORE REGULAR
OCCURRENCE. RECENT DATA FROM UC
IRVINE FOUND THAT LGBT C¯ PLUS
INDIVIDUALS, PARTICULARLY LGBTQ
PLUS PERSONS OF COLOR, ARE
DISPLACED AT NEARLY DOUBLE THE
RATE OF CISGENDER AND
HETEROSEXUAL INDIVIDUALS. LGBTQ
PEOPLE ARE MORE AT RISK OF
EXPERIENCING WATER AND FOOD
INSECURITY, UNSANITARY
CONDITIONS, AND FEAR OF CRIME
FOLLOWING A DISASTER. THIS IS
BECAUSE STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES CONTINUE TO LACK A
CLEAR STRATEGY ON HOW TO
INTEGRATE LGBTQ PEOPLE INTO
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS, PLANNING
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE. SB 990
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
CONSULT WITH REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE LGBT COMMUNITY TO CREATE
POLICIES AND BEST PRACTICES TO
MORE EQUITABLY SERVE THE
COMMUNITY OF CALIFORNIANS DURING
NATURAL DISASTERS. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THESE POLICIES AND
PRACTICES TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
NEXT UPDATE TO THE STATE. CAL
EOS PLANNING AND UNDERSTANDING
HOW TO BETTER SERVE LGBTQ
CALIFORNIANS WHEN DISASTER
STRIKES. THIS BILL IS SPONSORED
BY EQUALITY CALIFORNIA INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER, COMMISSIONER LARA,
AND THE LGBTQ CAUCUS. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DEL. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO JONES. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLI.
GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. MIN
WHEN NO. NILO OCHOA. AYE. SATO
WILK. AYES 32. NOES ONE. MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT THREE ON DECK IS
FILE ITEM 234 OR 236 AND 237.
MAJORITY LEADER, ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR 230? FOR SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 991 BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ. AN ACT
RELATING TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB 991 WHICH WILL REMOVE
THE SUNSET DATE FROM CURRENT LAW
TO ALLOW THE LAUSD OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO CONTINUE
ITS TRANSPARENT OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES IN PERPETUITY.
Kò A DISTRICT IS LARGE AND
DIVERSE, AS LA USD IS EXTREMELY
UNIQUE AND DESERVES A SPECIAL
ATTENTION TO ENSURE THERE IS NO
WASTE, FRAUD, OR ABUSE, AND IT
SIMPLY REMOVES THE SUNSET. THE
20 2025 SUNSET DATE AND ALLOWS
LAUSD TO MAINTAIN A MEANINGFUL
AUTHORITY TO ENSURE THAT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF CONTRACTS,
PROCUREMENT CONTRACTS, STUDENT
SERVICES, AND OTHER IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS DO NOT FALL VICTIM TO
POOR PERFORMANCE OR ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. NØ DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA. BORG
. AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO NO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL NO. DURAZO. AYE
MIN. AYES 31. NOS. EIGHT.
MEASURE PASSES FOR ITEM 236.
SENATOR DODD, ARE YOU PREPARED?
O SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1003 BY SENATOR DODD. ENACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY. SENATOR
DODD. MADAM PRESIDENT, MEMBERS
SB 1003 DIRECTS THE OFFICE OF
ELECTRICAL INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY
TO CONSIDER TIMELINESS AND COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES
WHEN REVIEWING WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS. WE ARE ALL
AWARE OF THE $13.5 BILLION RATE
INCREASE THE CPUC APPROVED FOR
PGE. THE CPUC IS ALSO RECENTLY
APPROVED AN ADDITIONAL RATE
INCREASE, ALLOWING PGE TO
RECOVER PAST EXPENDITURES MADE
IN 2020 AND 2022. TOGETHER THESE
RATE INCREASES WILL ADD MORE
THAN $400 ANNUALLY TO A TYPICAL
PGE ELECTRIC BILL. MOST OF THESE
RATE INCREASES ARE ATTRIBUTABLE
ATTRIBUTABLE TO WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND IN PARTICULAR,
THE UNDERGROUNDING OF ELECTRIC
CABLE UNDERGROUNDING COSTS $3
MILLION A MILE, WHILE
ALTERNATIVES SUCH AS COVERED
CONDUCTOR COSTS LESS THAN A
THIRD OF THAT. RATEPAYERS WANT
TO KNOW IF THE WILDFIRE
PROTECTION THEY ARE PAYING FOR
AND UTILITY BILLS IS BEING
PROVIDED IN THE SHORTEST AMOUNT
OF TIME, AT THE MOST REASONABLE
COST. SB 1003 SIMPLY DIRECTS THE
IOUS TO PERFORM THAT ANALYSIS
WHEN THEY UPDATE THEIR WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS EVERY THREE
YEARS. SB 103 1003 IS SUPPORTED
BY TURN, THE PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION LEAGUE, THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU, AND
OTHERS, AND I'M UNAWARE OF ANY
FORMAL OPPOSITION. RESPECTFULLY
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM 236.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BREAKSPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE.
WHEN I. NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BOG
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HURTADO. AYE. MEN. AYES 39. NO.
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO ITEM 237. SENATOR PADILLA,
ARE YOU PREPARED? HE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1006 BY SENATOR
PADILLA. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY. SENATOR. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TO PRESENT SB 1006, WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE UTILITIES TO
PREPARE A GRID ENHANCING
TECHNOLOGY STRATEGIC PLAN TO
COST EFFECTIVELY INCREASE
TRANSMISSION CAPACITY. AS WE
WELL KNOW, THE CAL ISO ESTIMATES
THAT WE WILL NEED MORE THAN
7000MW OF NEW TRANSMISSION
CAPACITY EVERY YEAR FOR THE NEXT
DECADE TO MEET OUR ENERGY
DEMANDS. HOWEVER, CALIFORNIA IS
FAR FROM ACHIEVING THIS
ESTIMATE, THREATENING OUR CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS. GRID ENHANCING
TECHNOLOGIES CAN INCREASE
CAPACITY, DECREASE CONGESTION,
IMPROVE RELIABILITY IN A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY, SUCH AS
REDIRECTING ENERGY AWAY FROM
OVERLOADED LINES AND ONTO
UNDERUTILIZED ONES, WHICH CAN
ENHANCE THE EXISTING GRID. THEY
ARE FAR CHEAPER AND FASTER TO
INSTALL THE NEW LINES. THE BILL
REQUIRES TRANSMISSION UTILITIES
TO COMPLETE A STRATEGIC PLAN FOR
GRID ENHANCING TECHNOLOGIES, AND
AN EVALUATION OF WHAT THESE
LINES WHICH LINES CAN BE
RECONSTRUCTED IN A COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER EVERY FOUR
YEARS. EVERY YEAR, CALIFORNIA
LOSES $1.5 BILLION TO GRID
CONGESTION, AND THESE STRATEGIES
CAN HELP SAVE 650 MILLION.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND
UPGRADE EXISTING TRANSMISSION
LINES TO EXPAND CAPACITY AND
DELIVER RELIABLE ENERGY AT LOWER
COSTS. THIS BILL HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MINH NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. AYE. OKUBO.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS MEN.
WHEN I. AYES 39. NØ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATORS, WE'RE
DOING AN AMAZING JOB ZOOMING
THROUGH THESE. NEXT THREE UP ARE
TWO, FIVE. ITEM 247, 252 AND
255. SENATOR PADILLA, BACK TO
YOU. YOU ARE PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1105 BY SENATOR PADILLA. AN
ACT RELATING TO PAY SICK LEAVE.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
PRESENT SB 1105, WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE THAT PAID SICK LEAVE BE
GRANTED TO AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
CAN ALSO BE UTILIZED TO AVOID
SMOKE, HEAT OR FLOODING
CONDITIONS CREATED BY A LOCAL OR
STATE EMERGENCY WORKPLACE
CONDITIONS EXPOSE FARM WORKERS
TO SEVERAL ADVERSE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS AND HAZARDS RESULTING
FROM EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS THAT
ENDANGER THEIR HEALTH, SAFETY,
AND ECONOMIC LIVELIHOOD,
INCLUDING WORKING UNDER
EXTREMELY HIGH TEMPERATURES.
EXPOSURE TO SMOKE FROM WILDFIRES
, AND RAIN. AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
ARE 35 TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DIE
FROM HEAT RELATED STRESS THAN
WORKERS IN ANY OTHER INDUSTRY.
IN THE UNITED STATES,
AGRICULTURE IS ONE OF THE MOST
HAZARDOUS INDUSTRIES IN THE
UNITED STATES, AND THE RAPIDLY
CHANGING CLIMATE WILL ONLY MAKE
MATTERS WORSE AS AVERAGE
TEMPERATURES INCREASE AND HEAT
WAVES, WILDFIRES AND EXTREME
RAIN EVENTS INCREASE, FARM
WORKERS WILL BE AT CONTINUED
RISK OF LOSING THEIR LIVES,
WHILE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS TAKEN SOME OF THE NATION'S
MOST PROACTIVE STEPS TO ADAPT,
ADOPT OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
STANDARDS AND SAFETY HAZARDS.
EXCUSE ME RELATED TO HEAT AND
SMOKE, FARM WORKERS NEED TO KNOW
THAT DURING CLIMATE EMERGENCY,
THEY ARE NOT RISKING THEIR
PERSONAL FINANCIAL DISASTER BY
CHOOSING THEIR SAFETY. SB 1105
IS A LATINO CAUCUS PRIORITY, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON ITEM 247
SEEING NONE, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAIN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NILO AYE. OCHOA. BORG
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBER. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLI. NÓ GROVE. JONES.
NO LIMON. AYE. MIN WHEN OCHOA.
BOGUE AYE. SATO NO. AYES 34.
THREE. NOS. THREE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM 252. SENATOR
BRADFORD, ARE YOU PREPARED? HE
IS READY. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1130 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. 1130
WOULD EXPAND THE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA FOR FAMILY ELECTRIC
RATE ASSISTANCE, BETTER KNOWN AS
THE FAIR PROGRAM, AND REQUIRE
THE STATE'S THREE LARGEST
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
REPORT ON THEIR EFFORTS TO
ENROLL CUSTOMERS IN THE FAIR
PROGRAM. BOTH THE FAIR AND THE
CARE PROGRAM ARE GROSSLY UNDER
ENROLLED, AND THIS WOULD JUST
BRING ATTENTION TO THESE BADLY
NEEDED PROGRAMS. AS UTILITY
PRICES GO UP AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM 252.
SEEING NONE, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO,
GILL ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NØ. LAIRD
AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. NEWMAN AYE.
WHEN I. NILO OCHOA. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WAHAB.
AYE ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MIN NILO. NÓ.
OCHOA. AYES 35. NOES THREE.
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM 255.
SENATOR CORTEZ, ARE YOU
PREPARED? HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1162 BY SENATOR CORTEZ. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
CONTRACTS. SENATOR CORTEZ. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB 1162. THIS BILL
ENABLES LABOR MANAGEMENT
COOPERATION COMMITTEES OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS LMCS, TO ACCURATELY
VERIFY WORKERS HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING BY
REQUIRING EMPLOYERS TO INCLUDE A
WORKER'S DATE OF BIRTH IN THEIR
MONTHLY CERTIFIED PAYROLL
REPORTS SUBMITTED TO LABOR
MANAGEMENT COOPERATION
COMMITTEES. BY ENSURING ACCURATE
IDENTIFICATION DATA, WE CAN
VERIFY WHETHER THE WORKER MEETS
THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA IN
ALIGNMENT WITH STATE
REGULATIONS. THE BILL HAS STRONG
SUPPORT AND NO KNOWN OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
ITEM 255. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN I NILO. AYE. OCHOA AYE.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GLAZER AYE. MIN.
PADILLA AYE. ISE 39. NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. SENATORS, WE ARE
TWO HOURS IN AND WE'VE DONE 44
BILLS. GREAT JOB. WE'RE ZOOMING
THROUGH NEXT. THREE ARE FILE
ITEM 265 272 AND 281. SENATOR
ALLEN, ARE YOU PREPARED FOR FILE
ITEM? 265? SENATOR ALLEN, ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR FILE ITEM 265?
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1297 BY SENATOR ALLEN AND
ACT RELATING TO VEHICLES.
SENATOR ALLEN. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, ON THE
EVENING OF OCTOBER 17TH, 2023, A
YOUNG MAN, SPEED AT 104 MILES AN
HOUR ON PACIFIC COAST HIGHWAY IN
MALIBU, LOST CONTROL OF HIS
VEHICLE AND KILLED FOUR
PEPPERDINE UNIVERSITY STUDENTS
STANDING ON THE SIDE OF THE
HIGHWAY. SINCE 2010, 60 PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN KILLED IN VEHICLE
ACCIDENTS. ALONG THIS VERY SAME
STRETCH OF BEAUTIFUL BUT
EXCEEDINGLY DANGEROUS ROADWAY.
MALIBU ONLY HAS ABOUT 10,000
PEOPLE, BUT IT RANKS IN THE TOP
25 SMALL CITIES WITH THE WORST
CRASH FATALITY RATES IN THE
COUNTRY. 2023 CRASH DATA FROM
THE L.A. COUNTY SHERIFF REPORTS
127 PROPERTY DAMAGE COLLISIONS
AND 93 INJURY COLLISIONS, SEVEN
DEATHS, A PRIMARY FACTOR IN ALL
OF THESE INCIDENTS WAS HIGH
VEHICLE SPEED. ONE VERY PROVEN
WAY TO SLOW DOWN DRIVERS IS
AUTOMATED SPEED CAMERA
ENFORCEMENT. THE NTSB, CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL, FEDERAL
HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION HAVE ALL
RECOMMENDED USING THIS TOOL TO
ENFORCE SPEED LIMITS. THE FACT
THE FHA, THE FEDERAL HIGHWAY
ADMINISTRATION DATA SHOWS THAT
THEY CAN REDUCE CRASHES ON URBAN
STREETS BY 54, AND AN NTSB
REVIEW OF SPEED CAMERA PROGRAMS
AROUND THE WORLD FOUND CAMERAS
TO BE EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING
FATAL COLLISIONS. THIS BILL
EXPANDS UPON AN EXISTING PILOT
PROGRAM, ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN'S LEGISLATION THAT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR, AND IT WOULD
BASICALLY APPLY IN A LIMITED
MANNER TO THIS ONE CITY, TO THIS
ONE STRETCH OF ROAD, THIS IS ALL
ABOUT TRYING TO SLOW PEOPLE DOWN
AND SAVE SOME LIVES. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON
THIS BILL. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON ITEM 265? SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NØ. LAIRD
AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO NO. OCHOA. NO.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CABALLERO AYE. MEN. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. AYES 36. NOES
THREE. MEASURE PASSES FOR ITEM
272 IS NEXT. SENATOR ARCHULETA
LOOKS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1330 BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA. AN ACT
RELATING TO WATER. SENATOR
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL 1330.
SENATE BILL 1330 WOULD ENACT
CHANGES TO THE 2018 MAKING WATER
CONSERVATION WAY OF LIFE LAWS
BASED ON RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE LEGISLATURE OF ANALYSIS
OFFICE REPORT FROM EARLIER THIS
YEAR. THE 2018 LAW HAS
ESTABLISHED A FRAMEWORK FOR LONG
TERM IMPROVEMENTS IN URBAN WATER
USE EFFICIENCY AND DROUGHT
PLANNING. AS CALIFORNIA ADAPTS
TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND IMPACTS,
THE STATE WATER BOARD IN
COORDINATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES, WAS REQUIRED
TO ADOPT LONG TERM STANDARDS,
VARIANCES, GUIDELINES,
METHODOLOGIES FOR CALCULATING
WATER URBAN WATER USAGE
OBJECTIVES BY JUNE OF 2022, DUE
TO THE COVID AND OTHER FACTORS,
WE ARE STILL AWAITING THOSE
REGULATIONS. THE PURPOSE OF MY
BILL IS TO EXTEND THE DEADLINES
OF THE 2018 LAWS TO MATCH THE
STATE WATER BOARD'S CURRENT
SCHEDULE, TO ADOPT FINAL
REGULATIONS TO REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES TO
UPDATE LANDSCAPE DATA IN THE
FUTURE, AND TO GIVE WATER
SUPPLIERS THE OPTION OF
REPORTING THEIR DATA ON EITHER A
CALENDAR OR FISCAL YEAR BASIS.
QUITE SIMPLY, SENATE BILL 1330
WILL PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY AND
COST SAVINGS FOR WATER SUPPLIERS
TO COMPLY WITH THE 2018 LAWS AND
PENDING STATE BOARD REGULATIONS,
SENATE BILL 1330 HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS NOT RECEIVED
ANY NÓ VOTES. FOR THESE REASONS,
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 39. NO ZERO.
MEASURE. PASSES. MOVING ON TO
ITEM 281. SENATOR ALLEN. YOU GOT
THE NEXT TWO. SENATOR ALLEN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 14. OH SIX BY SENATOR
ALLEN. AN ACT RELATING TO
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
SB 1406, WHICH ADDRESSES THE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS THAT
SENIORS ARE FACING IN ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITIES. WE KNOW THAT
SENIORS ARE THE FASTEST GROWING
POPULATION OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. AND
IN FACT, BY 2030, OUR SENIORS,
THE NUMBER OF SENIORS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IS
EXPECTED TO TRIPLE AND A MIXED
AMIDST THIS GROWING CHALLENGE.
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES HAVE
BEEN SERVING MANY, MANY PEOPLE,
BUT THERE ARE SOME UNSCRUPULOUS
FOLKS IN THIS SPACE,
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISING THE RATES THEY CHARGE
RESIDENTS LIKE NEVER BEFORE AND
PROFITING AT RATES LIKE NEVER
BEFORE. IN FACT, AN INDUSTRY
SURVEY SHOWS THAT HALF OF
ASSISTED LIVING OPERATORS EARN
RETURNS OF 20% OR MORE ABOVE THE
COST TO RUN THE FACILITIES,
WHILE THE RESIDENTS LIFE SAVINGS
ARE RAPIDLY DRAINED TO KEEP UP
WITH THE COSTS OF CARE. AND
UNLIKE MOST RESIDENTS OF NURSING
HOMES, WHERE CARE IS GENERALLY
PAID FOR BY MEDICAID, ASSISTED
LIVING RESIDENTS OR THEIR
FAMILIES ARE THE ONES THAT
USUALLY SHOULDER THE FULL COST.
SO DESPITE THE REQUIREMENT THAT
THESE FACILITIES INCLUDE
COMPREHENSIVE SUPERVISION AND
OBSERVATION, 1 TO 1 CARE AND AS
A BASIC SERVICE IS A COMMON ADD
ON IMPOSED ON RESIDENTS IN THE
CAN COST TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS MORE PER MONTH. THERE'S
NO PROCESS TO DISPUTE THESE ADD
ON CHARGES, NO REQUIREMENT THAT
THESE SERVICES BE REVIEWED BY A
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER. AND SO
THIS IS ULTIMATELY ALL ABOUT
TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGE THAT IS
OFTENTIMES SPRUNG ON FAMILIES.
AND AT A MOMENT WHERE THEY'RE
MOST VULNERABLE. WE'RE TRYING TO
PUT SOME SOME LIMITS ON SOME OF
THIS USURIOUS BEHAVIOR. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM 281
SEEING NONE, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI NÓ. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. NO. OCHOA. BORG
PADILLA. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. NØ.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE. NÓ. JONES NO. MIN. NGUYEN
NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA AYE. WILK.
AYES 31. NO. ZERO. NO. SEVEN.
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 282. SENATOR ALLEN
AGAIN. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1450 BY SENATOR
ALLEN AND ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS. SENATOR ALLEN, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. BACK IN
2016, I AUTHORED SB 450, WHICH
IS THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT, WHICH
OFFERS COUNTIES A NEW WAY TO
CONDUCT ELECTIONS BY INCREASING
ACCESS AND CONVENIENCE FOR
VOTERS AS MOST OF YOU KNOW,
UNDER THE VCA, COUNTIES CAN
CHOOSE TO SWITCH FROM THE
TRADITIONAL NEIGHBORHOOD POLLING
PLACES ON ELECTION DAY TO ASSIST
THEM. THAT OFFERS SEVERAL DAYS
OF EARLY VOTING VOTE BY MAIL FOR
ALL VOTERS, SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION, ACCESSIBLE VOTING
MACHINES FOR VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES. ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE SUPPORT SERVICES, AND
THE ABILITY FOR VOTERS TO VOTE
AT ANY LOCATION IN THE COUNTY.
AND I KNOW THAT SO MANY OF US
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS. YOU'RE IN ANOTHER PART
OF THE COUNTY A COUPLE DAYS
BEFORE ELECTION DAY. HEY,
THERE'S A CENTER THERE. YOU CAN
VOTE. SO SOMETHING LIKE 20
MILLION VOTERS, 77% OF THE
ELIGIBLE VOTING POPULATION, LIVE
IN ONE OF THE 29 COUNTIES THAT
HAVE ADOPTED THE VCA. NOW, THERE
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF BENEFICIAL
ASPECTS, INCLUDING INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY, COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. WITH THE ELECTION
PROCESS, AS WELL AS FAR FEWER
REPORTED VOTING PROBLEMS AT VOTE
CENTERS AND INCREASED ACCESS FOR
BILINGUAL POLL WORKERS. BUT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED BY COUNTY
CLERKS AND OTHERS. HURDLES OF
CONDUCTING ELECTIONS UNDER THIS
MODEL. SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO
STREAMLINE ADMINISTRATION,
IMPROVING ELECTION MANAGEMENT
UNDER THE VCA WHILE PROTECTING
VITAL VOTER ACCESS REQUIREMENTS.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION
ON ITEM 282. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MINH NEWMAN. AYE.
WHEN NILO. OCHOA. BOGH PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMMER. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TALLY.
GROVE. JONES MINH. NGUYEN NILO.
OCHOA. BOGUE CIERTO WILK. AYE
AYES 32. NO ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. ALL RIGHT, SENATORS, THE
GOOD NEWS IS WE FINISHED THE
LIST. THE GOOD NEWS IS THE OTHER
GOOD NEWS IS THERE'S ANOTHER
LIST SO WE CAN SHAVE TIME. AND
THE OTHER DAYS IT COMES. SO GIVE
US A COUPLE OF MINUTES. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A PAUSE. STAY IN
THE AREA AND WE'LL GET BACK TO
YOU. 30S WE'RE JUST STRETCHING
OUR ARMS. 30S. THAT'S ALL YOU
GET
.
ALL RIGHT. 30S IS UP. WE ARE
MOVING ON WITH BUSINESS. ALL
RIGHT, SENATORS, IF WE HAVE ANY
CONVERSATIONS, WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THEM OFF THE FLOOR. WE'RE
GOING TO NOW TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING THREE FILE ITEM 190,
FILE ITEM 229, AND FILE ITEM
157. SENATOR PADILLA, ARE YOU
READY TO KICK US OFF WITH FILE
ITEM 190 SR 91? SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION 91
BY SENATOR PADILLA. RELATIVE TO
HARVEY MILK DAY. SENATOR
PADILLA, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SR
91, WHICH WILL RECOGNIZE THIS
WEDNESDAY. ON MAY 22ND, HARVEY
MILK DAY. WE WILL HONOR HARVEY
BERNARD MILK, A HERO IN THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY WHO DEDICATED
HIS LIFE TO FIGHTING FOR THE
RIGHTS OF ALL PEOPLE. HE WAS THE
FIRST OPENLY GAY ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN CALIFORNIA AND IN
ANY MAJOR U.S. CITY. HE IS A
GLOBAL FIGURE, AN ICON, AND A
PIONEER IN THE LGBTQ CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT. THIS WAS NOT
ALWAYS THE CASE, HOWEVER. MILK
UNSUCCESSFULLY RAN IN SEVERAL
LOCAL ELECTIONS, BUT HIS
PRESENCE WAS FINALLY REWARDED IN
1977 WHEN HE WAS ELECTED TO THE
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISOR. HIS UNPRECEDENTED
ELECTION VICTORY AND THE POWER
OF HIS ADVOCACY AS AN ELECTED
LEADER CONTINUE TO INSPIRE US
TODAY AS LGBTQ REPRESENTATION
CONTINUES TO GROW ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, THE COUNTRY, AND THE
WORLD. HIS VOICE WAS OFTEN
LOUDEST TO FIGHT AGAINST
HOMOPHOBIA AND OTHER FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION, AT A TIME WHEN
MANY WERE AFRAID TO JUST SIMPLY
BE THEMSELVES. HE ACTIVELY
ENCOURAGED MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY TO SHOW PRIDE AND
EXPRESS THEIR TRUE IDENTITIES.
HE WAS ADAMANT THAT OUR
COMMUNITY MUST BE VISIBLE FOR
INVISIBLE, HE SAID. WE REMAIN IN
LIMBO, A MYTH, A PERSON WITH NO
PARENTS, NO BROTHERS, NO
SISTERS, NO FRIENDS WHO ARE
STRAIGHT, NO IMPORTANT POSITIONS
IN EMPLOYMENT. HIS LIFE WAS
TRAGICALLY CUT SHORT AFTER A
FORMER COLLEAGUE ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, ASSASSIN OUTED HIM,
AND SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR GEORGE
MOSCONE, HIS KILLER, WAS
CONVICTED OF MANSLAUGHTER
INSTEAD OF MURDER, AN INJUSTICE
THAT SERVES AS A STARK REMINDER
THAT WE MUST ALWAYS BE VIGILANT
IN ENSURING FAIRNESS. AND EQUITY
IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM. IN A
WORLD WITHOUT ENSURING EQUALITY
FOR ALL. HIS IMPACT AS A
TRAILBLAZER AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ADVOCATE MOVES US TO CONTINUE
THE FIGHT AND FINISH WHAT WE
STARTED. COLLEAGUES, I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SR 91. SENATOR WIENER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SR 91 AS A GAY JEW LIKE HARVEY
MILK WAS A GAY JEW. I ALSO HAD
THE HONOR OF REPRESENTING THE
SUPERVISORIAL DISTRICT THAT
SUPERVISOR MILK REPRESENT
RENTED. AND HE IS. HARVEY'S
MEMORY IS DEEPLY INGRAINED IN
SAN FRANCISCO. SO MANY CORE
VALUES THAT HE STOOD FOR. AND I
ALSO JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT ONE
OF THE IN THE SHORT TIME THAT
HARVEY WAS IN OFFICE BEFORE HE
WAS MURDERED, HE PLAYED A KEY
ROLE CAMPAIGNING AGAINST
PROPOSITION SIX, WHICH WOULD
HAVE BANNED LGBTQ PEOPLE FROM
BEING TEACHERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. A COMPLETELY HATEFUL
BALLOT MEASURE TARGETING AND
DEMONIZING OUR COMMUNITY. AND I
JUST WANT TO TIE THAT TO TODAY
BECAUSE, ONCE AGAIN, NEARLY,
ALMOST 50 YEARS LATER, WE ARE
ONCE AGAIN SEEING A RESURGENCE
OF THESE HATE HATEFUL BALLOT
MEASURES, HATEFUL LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS AROUND THE COUNTRY
TARGETING OUR COMMUNITY. AND SO,
HARVEY, I KNOW, IS BOTH SMILING
DOWN ON US AND ALSO LOOKING
INTENTLY AT US TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. AND WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY DO SO. I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SENATOR ATKINS, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I JUST WANTED TO ADD
A LITTLE BIT BEFORE, SUPERVISOR
MILK MADE HIS WAY TO SAN
FRANCISCO. HE SPENT A LITTLE
TIME IN SAN DIEGO. MANY OF US
ARE WEARING RED, WHITE AND BLUE
TODAY. YOU KNOW, TO GIVE US A
LITTLE BIT OF ENTHUSIASM AND
ENERGY TODAY, HARVEY MILK SERVED
IN THE US NAVY, AND HE WAS VERY
PATRIOTIC. AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE RECORD REFLECTS HIS
SERVICE TO COUNTRY. AND ONE OF
THE BEST TIMES I WAS ABLE TO GO
TO THE BAY AREA AS THE
ADMINISTRATION CAME OUT AND
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO NAME A SHIP AFTER
HARVEY MILK, AND THEN THAT SHIP,
WAS BUILT IN SAN DIEGO. SO ALL
OF THOSE THINGS, AS SOMEONE
GROWING UP IN SOUTHWEST VIRGINIA
AND I ACTUALLY SAW ON TV THE
TRAGEDY WHEN HE DIED AND, I
DON'T KNOW, FOR SOME OF US, IT'S
VERY PERSONAL. HAVING GROWN UP
AND COME OUT AS A MEMBER OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY IN SOUTHWEST
VIRGINIA, VERY DIFFICULT PLACE
TO DO THAT. BUT TO SEE HOW
HISTORY EMBRACES US ALL AND TO
KNOW THAT HIS NEPHEW, STUART
MILK, CARRIES ON THIS WORK, IN
HONOR OF HIS UNCLE, SO THAT A
LIFE THAT WAS TAKEN WAY TOO
SOON, IS REALLY A CONTINUATION
OF A LEGACY THAT WE ALL GET TO
PARTICIPATE IN. AND CELEBRATE.
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
RESOLUTION FORWARD, ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY OF A REALLY GREAT
MAN. THANK YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR
CABALLERO, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS, IT'S MY HONOR TO RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SR
91. IT'S, I THINK, REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STAND UP ON THIS
FLOOR AND RECOGNIZE AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO CHANGED HISTORY
AND HE CHANGED HISTORY BECAUSE
HE WAS THE FIRST AND BEING THE
FIRST MEANS THAT YOU'RE OUT
THERE. IT MEANS AT A TIME WHEN
PEOPLE HAVE BAD THOUGHTS AND
THEY'RE FREE TO SAY THEM, AND
THERE'S A MISUNDERSTANDING OF
THE COMMUNITY. K¾T IT'S TOUGH TO
BE THE FIRST. AND HE WAS THE
FIRST, THE FIRST TO RUN FOR
ELECTED OFFICE. AND AS YOU KNOW,
HE RAN AND WAS SUCCESSFUL AT,
WINNING A SEAT ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
HE WAS ABLE THROUGH HIS
DEDICATION AND HIS TALENT AND
HIS PERSEVERANCE TO MAKE A
STATEMENT THAT COST HIM HIS LIFE
TO MAKE, TO LIVE BY EXAMPLE, AND
DO SO MANY GREAT THINGS. AND
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT IT WAS
ONLY IN 1977 THAT THIS HAPPENED.
HE KNEW HIS POSITION WOULD COME
WITH ALMOST CERTAIN DANGER, YET
HE WAS ESTABLISHED. HE WAS
CHALLENGING THE ESTABLISHED
NORMS, AND HE PUSHED FORWARD.
WHILE HE WAS IN OFFICE, HE
WORKED TO PASS A GAY RIGHTS
ORDINANCE IN SAN FRANCISCO AS MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO SAID, HELPED TO DEFEAT
A STATEWIDE INITIATIVE THAT
WOULD HAVE BANNED GAY TEACHERS
FROM WORKING IN STATE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. HE ENCOURAGED LGBTQ
PLUS PEOPLE TO BE VISIBLE IN
SOCIETY AND FORGED COALITIONS
WITH OTHER MINORITY LEADERS TO
FIGHT AGAINST ALL FORMS OF
OPPRESSION. BUT AS WE KNOW,
DANGER EVENTUALLY FOUND HIM AND
HE WAS ASSASSINATED BY A FORMER
COLLEAGUE AFTER SERVING JUST 11
MEANINGFUL MONTHS IN OFFICE.
WITH CHILLING FORESIGHT, MILK
MADE A TAPE RECORDING WITH
INSTRUCTIONS TO HAVE IT READ
ONLY IF HE DIED BY ASSASSINATION
. ASSASSINATION. AND, YOU KNOW,
IT'S CHILLING BECAUSE MANY
LEADERS, CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS
HAVE HAD PREMONITIONS, AND IT'S
SCARY TO THINK ABOUT THAT ENTITY
SAYS IF A BULLET SHOULD ENTER MY
BRAIN, LET THAT BULLET DESTROY
EVERY CLOSET DOOR. A REALLY
POWERFUL STATEMENT ABOUT WHO HE
WAS AND WHAT HE WAS WILLING TO
DO IN ORDER TO BE, TO BE OUT
THERE AND TO BE THE FIRST. THE
LEGACY LEFT BY THE MAYOR OF
CASTRO STREET AND THE COURAGE HE
SHOWED CONTINUES TO BE
APPRECIATED AND FELT TODAY. HIS
HIS RECOGNITION AS ONE OF TIME
MAGAZINE'S MOST INFLUENTIAL
PEOPLE OF THE 20TH CENTURY AND
THE NUMEROUS INSTITUTIONS AND
ORGANIZATIONS NAMED AFTER HIM
ATTEST TO HIS IMPACT IN
CALIFORNIA, IN THE UNITED
STATES, AND QUITE FRANKLY, ALL
OVER THE WORLD. TODAY, AS WE
CELEBRATE HARVEY MILK DAY, LET
US ALL FIND THE COURAGE TO LIVE
OUR LIVES UNAPOLOGETICALLY AND
GENUINELY TRUE TO OURSELVES. LET
US RECOMMIT OURSELVES TO
ENSURING ALL MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES, ESPECIALLY THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY, ARE TREATED
FAIRLY, EQUITABLY AND
RESPECTFULLY IN ALL ASPECTS OF
OUR SOCIETY. AND MAY WE CONTINUE
OUR WORK AND THE WORK OF HARVEY
MILK TO ENSURE EVERY CALIFORNIAN
CAN LIVE A LIFE FULL OF LOVE,
PEACE AND HAPPINESS. ON BEHALF
OF THE LATINO LATINO CAUCUS, I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION, AND ASKED
ALL MEMBERS TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING SB 91. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON SENATOR PADILLA? YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. JONES.
LAIRD AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. BOGH
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE SATO.
SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLI. GROVE. JONES MIN. NGUYEN
NILO. NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BORG
SATO. WILK. AYE AYES 33. NO.
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT
THREE WE HAVE ON FILE. FILE ITEM
229, 157 AND 173. SENATOR
SKINNER, ARE YOU PREPARED? SHE
IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 976 BY SENATOR
SKINNER. AN ACT RELATING TO
YOUTH ADDICTION. SENATOR, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS,
I'M VERY PLEASED TO COME BEFORE
YOU TODAY WITH SB 976, A BILL
THAT IS DIRECTED TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN AND EMPOWER OUR PARENTS
AGAINST THE HARMS THAT WE KNOW
THAT SOCIAL MEDIA HAS BEEN
CAUSING. SB 976 WAS DEVELOPED
WITH INPUT FROM OUR SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS, COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS, PEDIATRICIANS,
AND MANY MORE TO ADDRESS THESE
WELL-DOCUMENTED HARMS. AND IT
DOES SO BY FOCUSING NOT ON
CONTENT, BECAUSE WE ARE
PROHIBITED FROM REGULATING
CONTENT ON THE INTERNET OR
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS, BUT
INSTEAD BY REGULATING THE
ADDICTIVE FEATURES THAT ARE
EMBEDDED IN THESE PLATFORMS. SO,
IN OTHER WORDS, THE ALGORITHMS
AND THE LA TIMES EDITORIAL BOARD
SO APTLY STATED THAT THE
ALGORITHMS ARE DESIGNED TO FEED
USERS A STEADY STREAM OF CONTENT
THAT THE USER DIDN'T NECESSARILY
ASK FOR, AND THAT THAT IT'S
DESIGNED TO KEEP THE USER ON THE
APP, WHICH IS WHY RESEARCHERS
HAVE DEFINED THE ALGORITHMS AS
ADDICTIVE. SO WHAT DOES SB 976
DO SPECIFICALLY? IT EMPOWERS
PARENTS AND IT MAKES PLATFORMS
SAFER BY REQUIRING OUR SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES TO FOR ALL USERS
WHO ARE MINORS TO TURN OFF THE
ALGORITHMS THAT SEND THE
ADDICTIVE FEEDS TO NOT SEND
NOTIFICATIONS DURING SCHOOL
HOURS AND BETWEEN MIDNIGHT AND 6
A.M. AND TO SET DEFAULT LIMITS
ON TIME SPENT ON THE PLATFORM
AND FURTHER, TO PROTECT
CHILDREN'S PRIVACY BY MAKING A
MINORS ACCOUNT PRIVATE AS A
DEFAULT SETTING. NOT SOMETHING
THAT EITHER A PARENT OR THE
MINOR HAS TO GO IN AND TINKER
WITH IN ORDER TO HAVE THAT
PRIVACY. NOW, ALL OF THESE
SETTINGS AND THIS IS WHERE WHEN
I REFERENCED EMPOWERING PARENTS,
ALL OF THESE SETTINGS CAN BE
CHANGED BY THE PARENT. IF A
PARENT, FOR EXAMPLE, WANTS
NOTIFICATIONS FROM THESE
PLATFORMS TO BE SENT TO THEIR
CHILDREN DURING SCHOOL HOURS,
THE PARENT CAN OVERRIDE IF THE
PARENT WANTS A LONGER TIME
PERIOD, RATHER THAN THE TIME
LIMIT. THAT'S THE DEFAULT IN
THIS BILL, THE PARENT CAN
OVERRIDE SO THE BILL FROM THAT
POINT OF VIEW IS REASONABLE AND
EMPOWERS OUR PARENTS AND GIVEN
US, UNFORTUNATELY, THAT SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES HAVE BEEN
UNWILLING SO FAR TO VOLUNTARILY
CHANGE THEIR PRACTICES. AS WE
OBSERVED IT AT THE CONGRESSIONAL
HEARING IN JANUARY. AND WE SEE
IT EVERY DAY AS OUR KIDS USE
THESE. AND WHEN THEY WON'T ACT,
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT
AND TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN. AND
WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR YES.
VOTE ON SB 976. SENATOR WIENER,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. I'LL
BE VOTING FOR THIS BILL TODAY
WITH SOME RESERVATIONS. AND THE
AUTHOR AND I HAVE DISCUSSED THEM
THAT ON BALANCE, THIS BILL DOES
A LOT OF GOOD BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME REAL HARMS THAT ARE
HAPPENING WITH KIDS. AND THE
ADDICTIVE NATURE OF THESE
SERVICES. AND SO I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S PERSEVERANCE AND
REALLY TRYING TO PROTECT A KIDS.
AND I THINK IN LARGE PART, THIS
BILL WILL HELP DO THAT,
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE ARE KIDS
WHO DON'T HAVE THAT KIND OF
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR PARENTS,
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE KIDS ARE ALSO TAKEN CARE
OF AND SOMETIMES ACCESS TO THESE
SERVICES CAN BE A LIFELINE FOR
THESE KIDS. AND SO I KNOW THAT
THE AUTHOR WILL ENGAGE ON THESE
ISSUES AND I TRUST HER,
INCREDIBLY, BECAUSE SHE, SHE
ABSOLUTELY GETS IT IN TERMS OF
THE NEEDS OF THESE KIDS. AND SO
I WILL BE VOTING FOR THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
EGGMAN. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED VERY
MUCH. MADAM PRESIDENT, I WANT TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL,
AND JUST TO SHARE A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE, I HAVE A 15 YEAR OLD
WHO HAS FINALS THIS WEEK. SO ALL
LAST WEEK SHE'S BEEN STUDYING
AND, TAKING FINALS. THIS WEEK.
AND SHE GAVE ME HER PHONE LAST
WEEK. SHE SAID, MOM, YOU GOT TO
KEEP IT FOR ME BECAUSE I JUST
KEEP GETTING SUCKED DOWN A
RABBIT HOLES. AND SHE TRIED
DELETING HER APP. SHE TRIED
DOING DIFFERENT THINGS. AND
FINALLY SHE SAID, HOLD IT FOR
ME, KEEP IT FOR ME, BECAUSE I
GET SUCKED DOWN A RABBIT HOLE.
OUR KID SHOULDN'T HAVE TO COME
TO US AND TELL US, BECAUSE NOT
EVERY KID IS GOING TO DO THAT
RIGHT. AND THERE'S SO MANY WHO
JUST GET SUCKED DOWN THAT HOLE
AND IT IT, IT JUST FEEDS THEM. I
CAN TELL YOU DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT ARE POPPING UP ON HER FEED
THAN POP UP ON MINE, SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE,
VOTE ON THIS. THAT THIS IS REAL.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION, SENATOR SKINNER? YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. AND IF I
COULD ADDRESS THE CONCERNS FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS BILL DOES NOT LIMIT A
MINOR'S SEARCH FOR WHATEVER
CONTENT THEY WANT TO SEARCH FOR.
IT DOES NOT LIMIT THAT. AND I
COMPLETELY RESPECT THAT THAT WE
HAVE WE DO HAVE CHILDREN THAT
SOMETIMES THEY FIND THEIR
COMMUNITY ON THE INTERNET, NOT
AT THEIR SCHOOL OR WITHIN THEIR
SOCIAL SETTINGS. THEY FIND THE
COMMUNITY THAT THEY CAN MOST
RELATE TO VIA SUCH PLATFORMS.
AND THERE IS NOTHING IN THE BILL
THAT WOULD PREVENT A CHILD FROM
THAT. AND IN FACT, WHAT THE BILL
DOES IS GOES BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL DESIGN. IN EFFECT, THE
DEFAULT THAT THE BILL REQUIRES
IS BASED BACK TO THE BASICS OF
THE ORIGINAL DESIGN OF FACEBOOK.
THE ORIGINAL DESIGN OF FACEBOOK
WAS BASED ON CHRONOLOGICAL FEEDS
AND WHAT YOU LIKED OR YOU
SEARCHED FOR. THAT'S WHAT CAME
TO YOU. NOT CONTENT THAT JUST
CAME TO YOU BASED ON THIS
ALGORITHM. SO IT WOULD ALLOW OUR
ANY MINOR TO BE ABLE TO SEARCH
FOR WHATEVER IT IS THAT THEY IF
THEY ARE, I'M PROBABLY GOING TO
DATE MYSELF. BUT FOR EXAMPLE, IF
THEY'RE PRIMARILY INTO, DUNGEONS
AND DRAGONS, YOU KNOW, IT
DOESN'T PREVENT THEM FROM THAT
OR ANY OTHER, ANY OTHER,
IDENTITY OR YOU NAME IT. SO I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE THAT
CLARITY. BUT I AM ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT
THIS BILL DOES ALLOW FOR MINORS
TO BE ABLE THOSE MINORS WHO NEED
TO BE ABLE TO FIND THEIR
COMMUNITIES THROUGH THE INTERNET
TO BE ABLE TO DO SO, AND WILLING
TO WORK ON THAT IF THERE IF AS
TIME GOES ON, THERE APPEARS TO
BE ANY PROBLEM RELATED TO IT.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO OCHOA. BADIA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. IRA
B¢O. AYE. CIERTO. NO SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
STERNE. AYE. UMMER. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MEN
NILO. OKOBO AYE. WILK AYES 35
NOES. TWO MEASURE PASSES. NOW ON
TO FILE ITEM 157. SENATOR
HURTADO, SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1155 BY SENATOR HURTADO. AN
ACT RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF 1974. SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1155,
WHICH AIMS TO BROADEN THE SCOPE
OF LOBBYING RESTRICTIONS BY
INCLUDING EXECUTIVE MEMBERS OF
STATE AGENCIES AND APPOINTED
OFFICIALS WHO RECEIVE A SALARY.
THE BILL PROPOSES A ONE YEAR
PROHIBITION PERIOD FOR THESE
OFFICIALS FROM ENGAGING IN
LOBBYING ACTIVITIES.
TRADITIONALLY, STATE REGULATIONS
HAVE IMPOSED SHORT COOLING OFF
PERIODS, ALLOWING OFFICIALS TO
QUICKLY MOVE INTO LOBBYING
POSITIONS AFTER GOVERNMENT. SB
1155 ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
PROPOSING A ONE YEAR COOLING OFF
PERIOD AND BY CREATING A LONGER
BUFFER PERIOD. THE BILL AIMS TO
REDUCE CONFLICTS OF INTEREST,
PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY AND RESTORE
TRUST AND INTEGRITY OF STATE
AGENCIES AND THE POLICY MAKING
PROCESS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FILE? ITEM 157
SEEING NONE MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL.
ANY OBJECTION? AYES 39. NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES ONTO FILE ITEM
173. SENATOR CABALLERO, ARE YOU
PREPARED? SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
. SENATE BILL 1134 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO. AN ACT RELATING TO
SURPLUS LAND. SENATOR THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS, I
RISE TO PRESENT SB 1134, WHICH
MAKES MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THE SURPLUS LAND ACT. LAST YEAR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND I
WORKED TO MAKE THE SURPLUS LAND
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT BECAUSE OF THE
ISSUES THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAD
AND HCD OVERSIGHT. OUR TWO BILLS
STRUCK A BALANCE TO PROVIDE
NECESSARY CLARITY TO ENSURE THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DISPOSING OF
LAND WERE DOING SO CORRECTLY
UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF THE ACT.
AFTER THEIR PASSAGE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT PROPOSED
DRAFT REGULATIONS TO THEIR
SURPLUS LAND ACT GUIDELINES AND
THEY MEMBERS DON'T HAVE TO. THEY
THEY DRAFTED EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS AS OPPOSED TO GOING
THROUGH THE ENTIRE APA PROCESS.
THIS BILL CODIFIES A SIMPLE
CLARIFYING CHANGE PROPOSED IN
THE DRAFT GUIDELINES TO ENSURE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE CLEAR
GUIDANCE WHEN DISPOSING OF
SEPARATE AND DISTINCT CONTIGUOUS
PARCELS TO A SINGULAR ENTITY, IN
THIS CASE, SEVERAL SEPARATE
PARCELS THAT ARE ADJOINED AND
SOLD TO ONE ENTITY ARE
CONSIDERED A SINGLE PARCEL FOR
PURPOSES OF MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE SLA FOR
DISPOSAL. THIS CLARITY HELPS TO
STREAMLINE THE DISPOSAL PROCESS
FOR LOCAL AGENCIES. HOWEVER, THE
DRAFT GUIDELINES IN MANY WAYS
ARE A SIGNIFICANT DEPARTURE FROM
WHAT WAS CONTEMPLATED AND
ULTIMATELY AGREED TO BY THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATURE, WHICH
THE STAFF ARTICULATES CLEARLY ON
PAGE FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS. OVER
THE FALL, I MET WITH HCD TO
DISCUSS THE CONCERNS THAT I HAD
WITH THEIR GUIDELINES AND TO
TELL THEM THEY WERE NOT
REFLECTIVE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT AND THE DIRECT LANGUAGE
OF THE BILL. AND BASED ON THE
CURRENT STATE OF THE DRAFT
GUIDELINES THAT THEY HAD, I FEAR
HCD WILL CONTINUE TO PUT FORWARD
GUIDELINES THAT ARE COUNTER TO
THE AGREEMENTS THAT WE MADE LAST
YEAR. THIS BILL SERVES AS A
VEHICLE TO MONITOR THE FINAL
GUIDELINES PROPOSED BY HCD AND
ENSURE THE AGREEMENTS REACHED
BETWEEN THE RESPECTIVE POLICY
COMMITTEES, MEMBERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS ARE FAITHFULLY
ADOPTED. AND THE REASON THIS
BECOMES REALLY IMPORTANT IS THIS
IS THE ONE AREA THAT WE ALLOW
HCD TO LOOK OVER THE SHOULDER OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO DECIDE
WHETHER THEY'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING, AND THEN TO ISSUE A FINE
OR, OR, OR A, RECALL OF THE, OF
THE PROPERTY THAT HAS BEEN
DISPOSED OF AS WAS DONE LAST
YEAR. ANY CHANGES PROPOSED BY
THIS BILL, ONCE THE FINAL
GUIDELINES ARE PUBLIC, WILL BE
THOROUGHLY VETTED WITH ALL
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS, AND I
COMMIT TO BRING THE BILL BACK
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL HEARING.
SHOULD THAT BE NECESSARY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. I
VOTE ANY DISCUSSION ON FINAL
ITEM 173. THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 39. NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT THREE
ON DECK ARE OUR FINAL ITEM 193,
213 AND 257. SENATOR HURTADO,
ARE YOU READY? SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1156 BY
SENATOR HURTADO, AN ACT RELATING
TO THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
1974. SENATOR THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 1156. YOU KNOW, MANY
SAY THAT WATER IS A NEW GOLD AND
THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERNS OUT
THERE BY COMMUNITY MEMBERS ABOUT
IT BEING JUST THAT. SO SB 1156
WOULD REQUIRE MEMBERS OF THE
EXECUTIVE TEAM AND BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES TO
ANNUALLY, ANNUALLY DISCLOSE ANY
ECONOMIC OR FINANCIAL INTERESTS
THEY MAY MAINTAIN. CURRENT LAW
LACKS APPROPRIATE TRANSPARENCY
MEASURES RELATING TO THESE GSA'S
. THIS INSUFFICIENCY CAN
INCREASE THE RISK OF ECONOMIC
INTEREST INFLUENCING DECISION
MAKING PROCESSES. ADDRESSING
THESE DEFICIENCIES IS IMPERATIVE
TO ESTABLISH EFFECTIVE
GOVERNANCE FRAMEWORKS THAT
PRIORITIZE THE LONG TERM HEALTH
AND SUSTAINABILITY OF
GROUNDWATER RESOURCES, REQUIRING
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY BY THOSE
BY THOSE IN POWER OF GSA SEEKS
TO SAFEGUARD THE SUSTAINABLE,
THE SUSTAINABLE MANAGEMENT OF
GROUNDWATER RESOURCES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL.
ANY OBJECTION? ALL RIGHT. AYES
39. NO. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR ASHBY, ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR FILE ITEM 213? SHE IS READ.
SHE IS READY. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ BIO ITEM 213.
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ITEM 213.
SENATE BILL 1439 BY SENATOR
ASHBY. AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE. SENATOR ASHBY. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1439. SB 1439 WILL
ALLOW SUTTER HOSPITAL IN
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO TO BUILD A
STATE OF THE ART CANCER CENTER
ON A FORMER REGIONAL TRANSIT LOT
, A LITTLE OVER A MILE FROM
WHERE WE STAND RIGHT NOW. SUTTER
HEALTH HAS ESTABLISHED ITSELF AS
A REPUTABLE PROVIDER OF QUALITY
HEALTH CARE IN MANY OF OUR
DISTRICTS. RIGHT HERE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA, THE BAY
AREA, CENTRAL VALLEY AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, MANY OF US
HAVE RELIED ON SUTTER HEALTH TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL, LIFE SAVING
CARE FOR OURSELVES OR OUR
FAMILIES. IN FACT, MANY OF YOU
HERE IN THIS ROOM HAVE RELAYED
STORIES TO ME OF YOUR TIME AT
SUTTER HEALTH, AT THIS EXACT
HOSPITAL IN SACRAMENTO. CANCER
IS THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH IN OUR STATE, WITH 199,000
NEW CASES AND OVER 60,000 DEATHS
EVERY YEAR, ACCORDING TO A STUDY
DONE BY UC DAVIS. SAC COUNTY
PERFORMED WORSE IN CANCER
MORTALITY WHEN COMPARED TO OTHER
STATE AVERAGES. THERE IS A GREAT
DISPARITY IN GETTING ACCESS TO
CRITICAL, LIFE SAVING CARE,
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
RECEIVING MEDI-CAL AND MEDICARE.
LOW INCOME PATIENTS ARE LESS
LIKELY TO RECEIVE LIFE SAVING
TREATMENT AND EXPERIENCE MUCH
HIGHER DEATH RATES FROM A CANCER
DIAGNOSIS. OF ITS, 3.2 MILLION
PATIENTS SERVED EVERY YEAR,
SUTTER SERVES OVER 1.2 MILLION
MEDI-CAL AND MEDICARE PATIENTS,
AND AS SENATE DISTRICT EIGHT
POPULATION GROWS SO TOO WILL
THAT NUMBER. SUTTER HEALTH IS
HEAVILY INVESTED IN OUR LOCAL
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS, SUCH AS WELLS SPACE
CENTER HERE IN MY DISTRICT, AND
WILL PROVIDE CARE FOR CANCER
PATIENTS FROM OUR MOST
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. THESE
ARE POPULATIONS WHO SEE HIGHER
RATES OF DEATH FROM CANCER
DIAGNOSIS DUE TO DELAY IN CARE.
THIS BILL OUTLINES SAFEGUARDS
THAT ENSURE THE LAND IS USED FOR
CRITICAL HEALTH CARE, AND
FURTHER ENSURES ACCESS FOR
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. I AM
PROUD TO HAVE THE SUPPORT OF
SUTTER HEALTH, SACRAMENTO'S
COMMUNITY CLINICS, INCLUDING
WEALTH, SPACE AND THE SACRAMENTO
NATIVE AMERICAN HEALTH CENTER,
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION, THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS,
PROVIDENCE SCRIPPS HEALTH, THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING AND
TRADES, AND SACRAMENTO'S LGBTQ
CENTER. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE, SENATOR MILLER,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I RISE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF SB 1439 AS A
FELLOW REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
SACRAMENTO REGION. SUTTER HEALTH
IS A CRUCIAL PROVIDER OF HEALTH
SERVICES THROUGHOUT OUR REGION.
AND THIS WILL ALLOW THEM TO
BETTER MEET THE NEEDS OF HEALTH
CARE IN OUR SACRAMENTO AREA OR
LOOKED AT ANOTHER WAY TO DENY
THIS WILL COMPROMISE THEIR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE QUALITY
HEALTH CARE TO OUR CITIZENS.
HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION. I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR
RUSSELL, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT, I RISE TO EXPRESS
SOME CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL AND
OFFER A BIT OF CONTEXT, THIS IS
NOT MY CONCERN IS NOT ABOUT THE
QUALITY OR THE NEED FOR HEALTH
CARE, ESPECIALLY IN SACRAMENTO
OR ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE CONTEXT IS THIS
THE SURPLUS LAND ACT IS A KEY
PIECE OF THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
ADVANCE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE
PREMISE IS SIMPLE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS SHOULD GET
THE FIRST SHOT AT PROPERTIES
THAT LOCAL AGENCIES NO LONGER
NEED. THIS BILL WAS THE SUBJECT
OF LENGTHY AND WOULD SPIRITED
DISCUSSIONS LEADING UP TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING THE OVERRIDING CONCERN
WAS HOW TO ENSURE THAT THIS
EXEMPTION DOESN'T UNDERMINE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND PROVIDES
A BENEFIT TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD BE HELPED, WOULD
OTHERWISE BE HELPED BY THE ACT.
THE SURPLUS LAND ACT. IT PASSED
OUT OF COMMITTEE WITH AMENDMENTS
I LED THAT NARROWED THE PARCELS,
TO THE PARCELS AT SUTTER, AND
INCLUDED STRONG REQUIREMENTS
THAT THE FACILITY TREAT MEDI-CAL
PATIENTS. SINCE THE HEARING,
HOWEVER, HAS COME TO LIGHT. THAT
SAC RT, WHICH OWNS THE PARCELS
AT THIS BILL AFFECTS HAS STARTED
ALREADY STARTED THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT PROCESS AND HAS RECEIVED
INTEREST FROM AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS ON THESE SITES. SAC
RT IS FOLLOWING THE STEPS IN THE
ACT, WHICH REQUIRES A 90 DAY
PERIOD OF GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS WITH ANY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO TRY TO
REACH AGREEMENT THAT NEGOTIATION
PROCESS MAY CONCLUDE BEFORE THIS
BILL GOES INTO EFFECT. BUT IF IT
DOESN'T AND SAC RT IS STILL
NEGOTIATING WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS WHEN THIS
BILL BECOMES EFFECTIVE, SAC RT
COULD SELL TO SUTTER,
UNDERCUTTING THE OPPORTUNITY WE
HAVE TO BUILD MORE HOUSING.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THIS
MOST RECENT INFORMATION, I AM
NOT ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND WILL BE LAYING OFF. THANK
YOU, SENATOR DALY. YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. I HEARD THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE, AND ALSO REPRESENT
PART OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND
THE SUTTER GROUP. AND ALSO COME
OUT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR 16
YEARS WHERE WE DID LAND PLANNING
AND NOW THE STATE HAS STEPPED
IN. DO WE ALL WANT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING? ABSOLUTELY. BUT IT
MAKES GOOD SENSE TO PUT HEALTH
CARE BY HEALTH CARE WHERE IT'S
ALREADY AT. FOR THOSE REASONS, I
THINK WE SHOULD PASS THIS BILL,
DO THE RIGHT THING. THERE ARE
MANY OTHER PLACES THAT THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, BUT THIS SITE IS SIMPLY
WOULD BE BEST USED FOR HEALTH
CARE FOR THE GREATER SACRAMENTO
AREA. SHE NARROWED THE BILL DOWN
TO JUST TAKE IN THAT ONE AREA
DID NOT MAKE IT A STATEWIDE
BILL. UNFORTUNATELY. I HAD OTHER
AREAS THAT MIGHT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO USE IT, BUT I COMMEND
THE AUTHOR FOR DOING THAT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM? SENATOR ASHBY, YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO JUST NOTE
THAT I HAVE TREMENDOUS RESPECT
FOR THE GOOD SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES AND AT HER REQUEST, DID
TAKE EXTENSIVE AMENDMENTS WHEN
THE BILL PASSED THROUGH HER
COMMITTEE. I RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH SOME OF HER
ASSERTIONS AND ANALYSIS TODAY,
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, THIS
BILL IS SO NARROW THAT IT ONLY
IMPACTS A COUPLE BLOCK RADIUS IN
MY DISTRICT ALONE AND SIMPLY
ALLOWS FOR ADDITIONAL SERVICES
FOR CANCER PATIENTS IN THE
REGION OF SACRAMENTO. I SPENT
MORE THAN A DECADE ON THE
SACRAMENTO CITY COUNCIL. IN THAT
TIME, I SERVED ON THE REGIONAL
TRANSIT BOARD AND ON THE SACOG
BOARD, AND ON ALMOST EVERY OTHER
REGIONAL BOARD IN SACRAMENTO. I
PROMISE YOU, I HAVE DONE MY
HOMEWORK. I ASK YOU TO HELP ME
HELP THE MILLION PEOPLE THAT I
REPRESENT HAVE ADDITIONAL ACCESS
TO CANCER TREATMENT AND LIFE
SAVING SERVICES BY ALLOWING THEM
TO BUY REGIONAL TRANSIT
PROPERTIES ADJACENT TO THE
EXISTING HOSPITAL THAT SERVES
MANY OF YOU AND YOUR FAMILIES,
AND ALMOST ALL OF MY
CONSTITUENTS IN THEIR FAMILIES.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. PLEASE
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. AYE DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO. AYE. OCHOA BOGUE. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE
. UMBERG. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DURAZO. EGGMAN
AYE. MIN. WAHAB. EYES 37. NÓ.
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 257. SENATOR PADILLA,
ARE YOU PREPARED? SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1208 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. AN ACT RELATING
TO SOLID WASTE. SENATOR. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1208. MY COMMUNITY IN THE
SOUTHERN REGION OF OUR STATE, AT
THE INTERNATIONAL BORDER IN
SOUTH SAN DIEGO COUNTY, HAS
ENDURED FAR MORE THAN ITS FAIR
SHARE OF POLLUTION AND TRASH AND
ADVERSE AND INAPPROPRIATE
ENVIRONMENTAL USES FOR DECADES,
THIS INCLUDES RENDERING PLANTS
WRECKING YARDS, LANDFILLS, GAS
FIRED POWER PLANTS ON OUR
WATERFRONT, GAS FIRED PEAKER
PLANTS ALL OVER DECADES
INTENTIONALLY LOCATED IN AN AREA
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR WITH LIMITED
ECONOMIC AND POLITICAL POWER TO
FIGHT BACK. JUST AS WE ARE
STARTING TO MAKE PROGRESS TO GET
RID OF DIRTY INDUSTRIES, WE ARE
FACING THE THREAT OF YET ANOTHER
LANDFILL MILES FROM AN EXISTING
ONE, TO BE BUILT IN THE MIDST OF
WHAT IS ONE OF THE STATE'S WORST
ENVIRONMENTAL CRISES. THROUGH A
MISLEADING BALLOT MEASURE POSED
TO THE COUNTY, NEARLY 15 YEARS
AGO, PRIVATE LANDOWNERS AND
DEVELOPERS ACHIEVED A ZONING
CHANGE THAT THEY MISLEADINGLY
REPRESENT AS A PROJECT APPROVAL
IN THE COUNTY'S GENERAL PLAN,
WHICH BASICALLY BYPASSES THE
REVIEW PROCESS, INCLUDING CEQA.
THE ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND, OF COURSE, THE PEOPLE WHO
ELECTED THEM. THE FACT IS, THIS
WAS DONE IN A DIFFERENT TIME,
AND THE NEEDS OF OUR COUNTY HAVE
CHANGED. ACCORDING TO THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO AND THE CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF EPA, OUR COUNTY HAS
MORE THAN SUFFICIENT LAND,
LANDFILL CAPACITY FOR AT LEAST
THE NEXT 30 YEARS. MOREOVER
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE LANDFILL,
NOT A SINGLE LANDFILL IN THE
STATE HAS BEEN APPROVED OR
ENTITLED IN THIS FASHION. ASIDE
FROM NOT NEEDING ANOTHER
LANDFILL IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY, WE
DON'T NEED IT IN ONE OF THE MOST
POLLUTED AND SENSITIVE
WATERSHEDS IN THE UNITED STATES.
SB 1208 WOULD PROHIBIT THE
REGIONAL BOARD FROM ISSUING A
PERMIT, A DISCHARGE PERMIT FOR
ANY NEW CLASS THREE LANDFILL
THAT FALLS WITHIN THE TIJUANA
RIVER NATIONAL ESTUARINE
RESEARCH RESERVE, OR AN AREA
THAT IS A TRIBUTARY TO THE
TIJUANA RIVER. THIS IS ONE OF
THE MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY
BURDENED, MOST DISTRESSED RIVERS
IN THE UNITED STATES, AND THIS
AREA HAS SOME OF THE WORST
CONCENTRATION OF INDUSTRIAL,
BIOLOGICAL, AND AIR POLLUTION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. VÀ. WE
CANNOT AFFORD NOT ONE MORE STRAW
ON THIS CAMEL'S BACK. FOR
DECADES, THE COMMUNITIES
SURROUNDING THE RIVER HAVE HAD
TO PUT UP WITH BEING TREATED AS
A DUMPING GROUND FOR OTHER
REGIONS OF THE STATE. THIS
COMMUNITY DOES NOT WANT AND
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO SUFFER AN
ADDITIONAL LANDFILL IN THIS
DISTRESSED ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTER. I URGE YOU TO VOTE AYE
TO PREVENT ANOTHER DUMPING
GROUND IN THE TIJUANA RIVER
WATERSHED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SEN. JONES.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I MUST
RESPECTFULLY RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO 1208 WITH ALL OF THE
COMPELLING ARGUMENTS THAT THE
AUTHOR SHARED, THOSE STATEMENTS
ARE ACCURATE. UNFORTUNATELY THE
PROBLEM WITH THIS PARTICULAR
AREA IS 75% OF THIS WATERSHED IS
LOCATED IN THE COUNTRY OF
MEXICO, AND 25% OF THIS
WATERSHED IS LOCATED IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AS
MANY OF US, OR MAYBE ALL OF US,
ARE AWARE THAT THESE POLLUTION
PROBLEMS ARE VERY EXACERBATED IN
THAT AREA, AND WE DO HAVE A LOT
OF PROBLEMS TO FIX. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HAS BEEN WORKING FOR DECADES
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF
MEXICO ON TRYING TO CLEAN UP AND
COME TO SOME AGREEMENT ON SOME
OF THESE OPERATIONS IN THIS
PROJECT IN PARTICULAR, THAT IS
LOCATED IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, HAS BEEN GOING
THROUGH THE PROPER PERMITTING
PROCESS THROUGH SEQUA AND THE
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARDS AND MEMBERS. I DON'T
THINK I NEED TO WALK THROUGH ALL
OF THE PROCEDURES THAT IT TAKES
TO GO THROUGH THOSE TWO
PERMITTING PROCESSES, PLUS ALL
OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT THIS
PROJECT IS HAVING TO COMPLY WITH
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
BILL IN PARTICULAR, IS
INTERFERING WITH LOCAL CONTROL,
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED, THAT THIS
PROJECT WAS SUBJECT TO VOTER
APPROVAL, 85% OF THE VOTERS IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY VOTED TO
APPROVE THIS PROJECT. THIS BILL
IN PARTICULAR, BANS THE WATER
QUALITY CONTROL BOARD FROM
ISSUING A PERMIT, ON A SPECIFIC
PROJECT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, I
WOULD ARGUE THAT IT'S NOT THE
SENATE'S RESPONSE ABILITY NOR
THE LEGISLATURE'S. ONCE WE PASS
THESE ENVIRONMENTALLY CONTROL,
BILLS AND LAWS THAT ARE
PROTECTING OUR ENVIRONMENT FOR
US TO COME BACK IN AND THEN,
USURP THE AUTHORITY THAT WE'VE
GIVEN THESE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
WHEN THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THIS
VERY RIGOROUS PROCESS OF
APPROVING THESE TYPES OF PERMITS
, THE VALLEY THAT THIS PROJECT
IS LOCATED IS VERY PRISTINE AND
VERY BEAUTIFUL. AND BECAUSE OF
THAT, IT HAS THERE'S BEEN A 1300
ACRE PRESERVE JUST RECENTLY,
PURCHASED BY THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY, NEARLY WITHIN
WALKING DISTANCE OF THIS
PROJECT. THE SO FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS, I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON SB 12. OH
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM,
SENATOR PADILLA, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, WITH GREAT RESPECT
TO MY DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUE,
JUST MAKE A FEW POINTS HERE. THE
FACT THAT 25, 75% OF THE
WATERSHED IS OCCUPIED BY THIS
PROJECT IS IMMATERIAL. THE
PROPOSED PROJECT LOCATION IS IN
THE WATERSHED, AND THE IMPACTS
OF SAID PROJECT WILL CONTRIBUTE
TO THE ADVERSE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS IN A WATERSHED THAT IS
ALREADY WELL DOCUMENTED AS
OVERBURDENED WITH RESPECT TO THE
ISSUE OF LOCAL CONTROL. THIS IS
2.0 IN A HANDBOOK OF TRICKS THAT
WE'VE SEEN BEFORE. A LITTLE OVER
A DECADE BEFORE THIS, A SIMILAR
LANDFILL WAS PROPOSED WITH THE
SAME EXACT PLAYBOOK TO GO AROUND
THE LOCAL VOTERS, BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES TO DO A ZONING
CHANGE FOR A LANDFILL THAT
AFFECTED A DIFFERENT WATERSHED
IN WEALTHY NORTHERN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY, ADJACENT TO PRIVATE
TRIBAL LANDS. AT THAT TIME, THE
OPPONENTS OF MY BILL WERE
ARGUING THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
WHAT THEY ARE ARGUING TODAY WITH
RESPECT TO THAT BILL, I CAN'T I
CAN'T OVERSTATE THE INCREDIBLE
HYPOCRISY INVOLVED THERE IN
TERMS OF VOTER APPROVED PROJECT.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR. THE VOTERS
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY APPROVED A
ZONING CHANGE FOR WHAT WAS
ADVERTISED TO THEM AS SOME KIND
OF A RECYCLING FACILITY, A 340
ACRE SITE. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
APPLICATION BEFORE THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS, 97% OF THE
SITE IS PROPOSED FOR A CLASS
THREE DUMP, A LANDFILL, AND ONLY
ABOUT 3% FOR SOME KIND OF AS YET
UNDEFINED RECYCLING SOMETHING OR
OTHER. AND IN TERMS OF PRECEDENT
FOR THE STATE LEGISLATURE
INTERVENING, THERE IS ALREADY
PRECEDENT. COLLEAGUES IN STATUTE
, FOR THIS LEGISLATURE TO DIRECT
THE WATER BOARD, NOT TO ISSUE A
DISCHARGE PERMIT IN EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS IS NOT A NEW
PRECEDENT SET ACT BY THE
LEGISLATURE. IT WOULD BE THE
MOST APPROPRIATE ACT BY THIS
LEGISLATURE AND COLLEAGUES IF
THIS ISSUE IN THIS PART OF OUR
STATE IS NOT A POSTER CHILD FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE, I DO NOT
KNOW WHAT IS. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO, GIL
ARCHULETA, AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE. DALLY.
NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. NO. OCHOA. BORG.
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMMER.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN. ALVARADO.
GILL CABALLERO. GROVE. NO. MIN
NGUYEN. NO ULTRABOOK. WILK AYES
28. NO. SIX MEASURE PASSES. THE
NEXT THREE ON DECK ARE GOING TO
BE FILE ITEM 239, 250 AND 254.
SENATOR EGGMAN, ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR FILE ITEM FILE ITEM 239. SHE
SHE IS PREPARED FOR ONCE. ARE
YOU READY? SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1025 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
DIVERSION. SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM SPEAKER.
THIS BILL SIMPLY EXPANDS THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR VETERAN
DIVERSION PROGRAMS TO MAKE IT
CONSISTENT WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION COURT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON FILE ITEM 239. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILMAN AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ DALLI.
DODD. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
ACIERTO. SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
AYE. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD AYE. JONES MINH.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. BOGUE SATO.
EYES 33. NO. ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES FIVE. ITEM 250. SENATOR
CABALLERO, ARE YOU PREPARED?
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1123 BY SENATOR CABALLERO.
AN ACT RELATING TO LAND USE.
SENATOR CABALLERO, THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1123, WHICH BUILDS
UPON WORK THAT I DID LAST YEAR
TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
COMMUNITIES TO BUILD SMALL
SCALE, MORE AFFORDABLE, INFILL
HOME OWNERSHIP PROJECTS. AS WE
KNOW, THE HIGH COST OF HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION AND REGULATORY
DELAY HAS CONTRIBUTED TO THE
STATE'S AFFORDABILITY CRISIS.
AND JUST LIKE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY HAS DRIVEN HOME
OWNERSHIP RATES DOWN FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR, LOCAL
PLANNING RULES HAVE ALSO CREATED
BARRIERS TO HOME OWNERSHIP, AND
MANY COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HAVE ENACTED POLICIES THAT
RESTRICT DENSER DEVELOPMENT IN
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS,
WHICH PREVENTS THE CONSTRUCTION
OF SMALLER STARTER HOMES.
WORKING FAMILIES CAN AFFORD TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES. LAST YEAR,
I INTRODUCED SB 684 TO
STREAMLINE THE SUBDIVISION OF
PARCELS FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
SMALL SCALE HOME OWNERSHIP
PROJECTS OF UP TO TEN UNITS
WHICH PASSED OFF THIS FLOOR WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OVER THE
COURSE OF THE FALL. I HEARD FROM
A VARIETY OF STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
NEED TO INCLUDE IMPORTANT
TECHNICAL, TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE LAW.
SB 1123 INCORPORATES THE
FEEDBACK THAT I RECEIVED TO
IMPROVE IMPLEMENTATION. IT
REESTABLISHES THE SUBDIVISION
AND PROJECT STREAMLINING
BENEFITS FOR SMALL PROJECTS OF
TEN UNITS OR LESS ON VACANT
PARCELS ZONED FOR SINGLE FAMILY
INFILL RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT,
AND IT ALSO UNLOCKS OPPORTUNITY
TO BUILD SMALLER HOMES ON SMALL
LOTS TO INCREASE HOME OWNERSHIP.
PROJECT IN SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS, WHICH HAVE A
HISTORY OF EXCLUDING LOW INCOME
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. BUT TO
ENSURE THE APPROPRIATE
GUARDRAILS IN PLACE, I'VE
INCLUDED THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MAY IMPOSE THE SAME HEIGHT,
HEIGHT STANDARDS AS THAT OF
NEIGHBORING PARCELS. THIS WILL
UNLOCK NEW DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITY, BUT ENSURE IT'S
CONSISTENT, CONSISTENT WITH THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. SENATORS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON ITEM 250?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DEL.
DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. NO. OCHOA BOG.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
NO. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DALY. GROVE MEN.
NGUYEN. NÓ. OCHOA BOK. SUGIARTO.
NO AYES 31 NOES FIVE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
254. SENATOR PORTANTINO, ARE YOU
PREPARED? HE IS SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1147 BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO. AN
EQUIVALENT TO DRINKING WATER.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1147, WHICH BUILDS UPON WORK
FROM 2018, WHERE WE DIRECTED THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO DEFINE
MICROPLASTICS AND DEVELOP
STANDARDS AND METHODS TO TEST
FOR MICROPLASTICS IN OUR
DRINKING WATER. MICROPLASTICS
HAVE BEEN FOUND EVERYWHERE FROM
OUR SOIL, AIR AND IN OUR OWN
BODIES. THOUGH WE KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE, MORE MOST MORE MUST BE
DONE TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
EXPOSURE AND CONSUMPTION OF
MICROPLASTICS AFFECTS OUR
HEALTH. WE DO KNOW, HOWEVER,
THAT WHEN INGESTED BY MARINE
LIFE, MICROPLASTICS HAVE BOTH
TOXIC AND MECHANICAL EFFECTS,
CAUSING A REDUCED FOOD INTAKE,
SUFFOCATION, BEHAVIORAL CHANGES
AND GENETIC ALTERATIONS. IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE PRIORITIZE
THE RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS OF
MICROPLASTICS FOR THE SAKE OF
PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
CURRENTLY, THE STATE WATER BOARD
IS WORKING TO ESTABLISH TESTING
METHODS, MONITORING STANDARDS
AND OTHER GOALS AS OUTLINED IN
THEIR 2022 POLICY HANDBOOK. ONCE
COMPLETED, IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT
WE HELP HOLD ALL SOURCES OF
DRINKING WATER TO THE SAME
STANDARD. AS SUCH, WE MUST BEGIN
MONITORING BOTTLED WATER ALONG
WITH TAP WATER. SB 1147 WILL
DIRECT THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARDS
ASSESSMENT TO PRIORITIZE
STUDYING THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF
MICROPLASTICS IN DRINKING WATER.
IT WILL ALSO WORK WITH THE STATE
WATER BOARD IN DEVELOPING HEALTH
GOALS TO ADDRESS MULTIPLE
MICROPLASTICS IN OUR DRINKING
WATER, INCLUDING BOTTLED WATER.
UNDER SB 1147, THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WILL COLLECT
MICROPLASTICS DATA FROM WATER
BOTTLING PLANTS THAT SELL
BOTTLED WATER IN CALIFORNIA ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS. SB 1147 IS A
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
IDENTIFYING MICROPLASTICS IN OUR
DRINKING WATER AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GILL. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. NO. OCHOA. BOGUE
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO.
NØ. SKINNER. AYE. SMALL CUEBAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE DALLY. GROVE. MIN
NGUYEN. OCHOA AYES 32. NOES.
THREE MEASURE PASSES. SENATORS.
THIS IS IT FOR BILLS LEFT. WE
GOT THIS. ALL RIGHT. LAST 4 OR
5. ITEM TWO 6283, 194 AND 274.
SENATOR RUBIO, ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR FIVE? ITEM 260. SENATOR
RUBIO. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1230 BY SENATOR
RUBIO, AN ACT TO TOBACCO SALES.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT SB
1230, THE STOP AND SEIZE ILLEGAL
TOBACCO PRODUCTS ACT. WE ALL
KNOW ABOUT THE HEALTH RISKS
CAUSED BY SMOKING AND THAT
MILLIONS HAVE DIED FROM TOBACCO
USE. CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
PROGRESS ON LOWERING SMOKING
RATES HERE IN OUR STATE. AND IN
RECENT YEARS, AS WE SAW TOBACCO
COMPANIES BEGIN TO HOOK A NEW
GENERATION OF KIDS TO FLAVORED
TOBACCO, WE TOOK DECISIVE ACTION
AS A BODY, AS A STATE TO BAN THE
SALE OF FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS. BUT THESE ILLEGAL
PRODUCTS CONTINUE TO FIND THEIR
WAY INTO CALIFORNIA AND INTO OUR
SCHOOLS. SB 1230 WILL STRENGTHEN
ENFORCEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S ANTI
TOBACCO LAWS AND ENSURE FLAVOR
VAPES ARE KEPT OFF THE SHELVES
AND OUT OF THE HANDS OF OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR YOUTH. THIS
BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
COALITION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS, INCLUDING THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION AND
THE CAMPAIGN FOR TOBACCO FREE
KIDS, AND IT HAS NO OPPOSITION
ON RECORD. PASSING THIS
LEGISLATION WILL SEND A MESSAGE
THAT CALIFORNIA CARES VERY
DEEPLY ABOUT OUR YOUTH, AND WE
WILL NOT ALLOW THE TOBACCO
INDUSTRY TO HOOK ANOTHER
GENERATION OF NICOTINE ADDICTS.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, ANY
DISCUSSION ON ITEM 260?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO AYE.
JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON. AYE
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. NGUYEN NILO. NO. OCHOA.
BORG PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE NO.
MIN. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN WILK.
AYES 31. NOS. FIVE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR ASHBY, ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR YOUR FILE? ITEM
283. SHE IS SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1453 BY
SENATOR ASHBY AND AQUILINO TO
HEALING ARTS. SENATOR ASHBY.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. SB
1453 IS THE DENTAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA'S SUNSET BILL FROM
THE BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
BILL MAKES A NUMBER OF CHANGES
TO IMPROVE THE BOARD'S
OPERATIONS AND EFFICIENCIES.
WITHOUT THIS BILL, THE BOARD
WOULD EXPIRE ON JANUARY 1ST. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION FOR ITEM
283, ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 39. NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. FINAL TWO. UP
NEXT FILE ITEM 194 IS SENATOR
DODD IS NOT PREPARED. I'M GOING
TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
SEVEN. WE'RE GOING TO GO MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM 274. SENATOR
BECKER, ARE YOU PREPARED? YES,
HE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM 274.
SENATE BILL 1374 BY SENATOR
BECKER. AN ACT RELATING TO
ENERGY. SENATOR BECKER, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO APPLY THE SAME
RULES FOR DISTRIBUTED SOLAR ON
SCHOOLS, APARTMENTS AND FARMS
THAT THEY DO NOW FOR SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES UNDER THE NEW NET
BILLING TARIFF. I'M SURE YOU ALL
YOU ALL HEARD A LOT ABOUT CALLED
NEM. THREE HOMES WITH ROOFTOP
SOLAR ARE ABLE TO SELF CONSUME
THE ENERGY THAT THEY GENERATE
THEMSELVES. IF THEY USE MORE
THAN THEY GENERATE IN A 15
MINUTE PERIOD, THEY PURCHASE THE
EXTRA ENERGY FROM THE UTILITIES
AT NORMAL ELECTRICAL RATES. IF
THEY GENERATE MORE THAN THEY
USE, THEN THEY SELL THAT EXCESS
ENERGY AT THE NEW LOW NEM THREE
RATES. SO AGAIN, THESE NEM THREE
CHANGES, THE TWO THAT I
MENTIONED, NUMBER ONE, NETTING
ENERGY USE DURING 15 MINUTE
INTERVALS AND TWO SELLING EXCESS
ENERGY AT A MUCH LOWER RATE.
THOSE WERE THE PUC SOLUTION TO
CONCERNS ABOUT A COST SHIFT THAT
THEY BELIEVED WAS LEADING TO
HIGHER ELECTRICITY RATES. WITH
THIS BILL SIMPLY DOES IS
REQUIRES THE PUC TO REQUIRE THE
SAME RULES AND APPLY THE SAME
RULES TO EVERYONE, INCLUDING
THAT ABILITY TO GET CREDIT FOR
SELF-CONSUMING THE ENERGY THAT
THAT YOU GENERATE BY A SCHOOL, A
FARM, A NONPROFIT, A COMMUNITY,
A CIVIC CENTER THAT IS
GENERATING NUMBER ONE FROM ITS
OWN SOLAR PANELS AND TWO
SIMULTANEOUSLY USING IT ON ITS
OWN PROPERTY. WITHOUT THAT, A
SCHOOL THAT BUILDS SOLAR IN ITS
PARKING LOT HAS TO SELL THAT
ENERGY TO THE GRID AT LOW NEM
THREE RATES AND SIMULTANEOUSLY
BUY BACK FROM THE GRID AT FOUR
TIMES THE PRICE, WHICH MAKES NO
SENSE IF WE WERE TO LIMIT THIS,
IT WOULD BE THE SAME AS AS
LIMITING, FOR EXAMPLE, ENERGY,
MORE ENERGY EFFICIENT APPLIANCES
. RIGHT? THESE ARE STUFF THAT WE
USE THAT WE CONSUME, THAT WE'RE
DOING OURSELVES WITH, THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SENATOR DALEY, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I HAVE TO
RISE IN OPPOSITION. EVEN THOUGH
MANY OF MY FRIENDS WHO ARE USING
THESE PROGRAMS ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, MEMBERS DURING COMMITTEE,
WE HAD A VERY LENGTHY DEBATE
ABOUT THIS BILL. AND THERE'S
BIPARTISAN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. WHY BECAUSE THIS BILL IS
ALLOWING SOMEBODY WHO HAS A
PIECE OF PROPERTY. LET'S JUST
TAKE FOR AN EXAMPLE, A FARM
ACROSS THE ROOM OVER THERE AND A
FARM ON THIS SIDE AND MAYBE
MILES APART. TO BE ABLE TO USE
THAT, BOTH OF THOSE PIECES OF
PROPERTY WITH SOLAR ON THEM, AS
ONE UNIT USING THE GRID, BY THE
WAY, TO TRANSFER THAT ENERGY. SO
WHY DO THOSE FOLKS WANT TO HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY? BECAUSE FOR
EVERY BIT OF SOLAR THAT WE
PRODUCE IN CALIFORNIA, THAT GETS
A BREAK. SOMEBODY ELSE IS PAYING
FOR IT. AND WE'VE HEARD A LOT,
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS AND A LOT OF
LEGISLATORS WHO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
SOLAR ARE PAYING FOR PEOPLE THAT
HAVE SOLAR. AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. LAST YEAR,
$6 BILLION WAS TRANSFERRED FROM
PEOPLE THAT HAVE SOLAR TO PEOPLE
THAT DON'T HAVE SOLAR. ACTUALLY
MORE MONEY THAN WHAT WE SPENT ON
RATES FOR HARDENING OUR SYSTEM
DUE TO WILDFIRE. SO IF WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT BILLS LIKE
THIS AND EXPECT RATES TO GO DOWN
FOR HARD WORKING, LOW INCOME
PEOPLE, THEY'RE NOT. BECAUSE
IT'S QUITE FRANKLY, COST
SHIFTING. AND SO I DON'T CARE
WHO SUPPORTS IT OR WHO DOESN'T
OR WHO'S IN, THERE'S VERY FEW IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE SUPPORTING IT
ARE GETTING A BREAK. AND WHO'S
PAYING FOR IT? LOW INCOME PEOPLE
WHO DON'T GET REPRESENTED HERE
VERY WELL BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A PAC OR A LOBBY TO HELP
THEM. BUT IF YOU VOTE AGAINST
THIS BILL, YOU'LL BE HELPING
THEM BECAUSE THE COST SHIFT IS
GOING TO THEM. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A NO VOTE ON 13.74 HELP LOW
INCOME PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
SURVIVE AND THE RATES WILL GO
DOWN IF WE STOP BAD LEGISLATION
LIKE THIS. THANK YOU. SENATOR NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION. SENATOR
BECKER, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU. I RESPECT, THE COMMENTS. I
DO WANT TO CLARIFY A COUPLE
THINGS. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT COST
SHIFT, THERE WAS CONCERNS AROUND
THE OLD M1 OR M2 RATES AND A
RESIDENTIAL THAT YOU WERE ABLE
TO GENERATE MORE AND SELL THAT
BACK AT VERY HIGH PRICES. NUMBER
ONE, WE TOOK YOU KNOW, THE PUC
ACTED ON THAT AND RIGHTLY OR
WRONGLY CREATED MUCH LOWER
RATES. BUT BUT WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT WITH THIS BILL IS
NONRESIDENTIAL AND THERE ARE
ACTUALLY NOT ALLOWED TO SHIFT,
COSTS BETWEEN RESIDENTIAL AND
NONRESIDENTIAL. SO THE ONLY WAY
THERE COULD BE A COST SHIFT IS
IF ENERGY USE WAS THE SAME OR
GOING DOWN, BUT THAT'S NOT THE
CASE. ENERGY USE IN THIS STATE
IS PROJECTED TO DOUBLE BY 2045.
SO ANYONE, ANY SCHOOL THAT PUTS
ON SOLAR AND SAVES ANYWHERE FROM
$300,000 TO $3 MILLION. AND BY
THE WAY, WE HAVE A JOINT OP ED
FROM THE CLOVIS, SUPERINTENDENT
AND THE OAKLAND SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENT, THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE, PROBABLY AND MOST
LIBERAL DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
WROTE A JOINT OP ED. BUT ANY SAY
SCHOOL THAT DOES THAT AND SAVES
THAT MONEY, THAT'S ONLY
PARTIALLY OFFSETTING THE
INCREASE IN ENERGY USE FROM
EVERYONE ELSE. SO THAT'S WHY
THERE WILL NOT BE. WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THERE WILL BE A COST
SHIFT IN THIS BILL. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SECRETARY
SENATOR SKINNER FOR WHAT? NO
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BREAKSPEAR AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI NO. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES NO. LAIRD LIMON. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA. BORG
NO. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD. DURAZZO EGGMAN. MIN
NEWMAN. AYES 28. NO. SEVEN. THE
MEASURE PASSES. SEN DODD WANTED
TO CLOSE THIS OUT, SO HE WILL BE
OUR LAST FILE ITEM. FILE ITEM
194. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1243 BY SENATOR DODD
AND ACT RELATING TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF 1974.
SEN. DODD MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1243 TO AMEND THE LEVINE ACT FOR
BETTER CLARITY, COMPLIANCE AND
FAIRNESS. THE LEVINE ACT LIMITS
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE BUSINESS BEFORE A QUASI
JUDICIAL BODY. IN 2022, THE
LEVINE ACT WAS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS.
PREVIOUSLY, THE LAW ONLY APPLIED
TO APPOINTED OFFICIALS. OVER THE
LAST YEAR, WE'VE HEARD FROM
NUMEROUS ELECTED OFFICIALS FROM
CITIES AND COUNTIES WHO HAVE
STRUGGLED TO IMPLEMENT THE LAW
AND FROM NUMEROUS ORGANIZATIONS
WHO HAVE STRUGGLED TO ADHERE TO
THE OVERLY COMPLICATED
REQUIREMENTS. THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF CHANGES TO THE
LEVINE ACT HAVE RESULTED IN
MAKING TRANSPARENT, DIRECT
CONTRIBUTIONS INFEASIBLE. THE
LAW ESSENTIALLY FREEZES OUT A
SECTOR OF THE COMMUNITY FROM
DONATING DIRECTLY TO CANDIDATES,
AND INSTEAD PROMOTES A VERY
UNDESIRABLE CONSEQUENCE IN
DEPENDENT EXPENDITURES POURING
INTO CAMPAIGNS MORE AND MORE,
AND IT CREATES THE RISK OF
STRATEGIC MISUSE BY PARTIES
WISHING TO FORCE A COUNCIL
MEMBER OR SUPERVISOR TO RECUSE
THEMSELVES. THIS BILL ADDRESSES
A NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT HAVE
ARISEN DURING IMPLEMENTATION.
THE BILL ADJUSTS THE
CONTRIBUTION LIMIT THAT HAS NOT
CHANGED SINCE 1982. FROM $250 TO
$1000, APPROXIMATING INFLATION.
IT ADJUSTS THE PROHIBITION
PERIOD BEFORE AND AFTER A
DECISION IS MADE FROM 12 MONTHS
TO NINE MONTHS, WHICH IS STILL 3
TO 3 TIMES LONGER THAN WHAT WAS
LAW 40 YEARS PRIOR TO THE 2022
CHANGE. AND IT CLARIFIES THAT
INCREASED MEMBERSHIP DUES FOR
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE UNIONS,
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE AND OTHER
ASSOCIATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE, THEY
DO NOT TRIGGER INCLUSION IN THIS
STATUTE WHEN THEY HAVE NO DIRECT
FINANCIAL STAKE IN THAT
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT. IT ALSO
SIMPLIFIES COMPLIANCE BY KEEPING
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM AGENTS IN A
PARTY OR PARTICIPANT, CALCULATED
SEPARATELY. VÆ. THIS BILL WILL
FURTHER THE GOALS OF THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT BY MAKING
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION CLEAR AND
WORKABLE, AND HELPING REMOVE
CONDITIONS THAT HAVE
INCENTIVIZED DARK MONEY POURING
INTO CAMPAIGNS. I'VE TAKEN
NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL
ON THE FLOOR, INCLUDING DELETING
THE EXEMPTION FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS, CLARIFYING
DEFINITIONS, AND PROHIBITING
AGENTS FROM DONATING WHILE A
PROJECT IS PENDING, ALL OF WHICH
WERE PROPOSED BY THE ELECTIONS
CHAIR. AND I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS ALIKE
TO IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS TO HELP ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING CONCERNS AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE, WHILE STILL SOLVING
THE PROBLEM AND CREATING A FAIR
SYSTEM. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE, SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE REASONS THAT I WILL
NOT BE SUPPORTING SB 1243 TODAY.
AT ISSUE IN THIS BILL ARE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO LOCALLY ELECTED
OFFICIALS FROM DONORS WHO ARE
ACTIVELY SEEKING A PERMIT OR
CONTRACT APPROVAL FROM THOSE
SAME ELECTED OFFICIALS. THIS
BILL RAISES THE AMOUNT OF A
PERMITTED CONTRIBUTION FROM $250
TO $1000, SHORTENS THE TIME
PERIOD DURING WHICH THE
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS APPLY,
LOOSENS LONG STANDING
AGGREGATION RULES THAT PROHIBIT
WHAT COULD BE MULTIPLE
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM THE SAME
ENTITY OR PERSON, AND CARVES OUT
ENTIRELY THOSE WHO PAY
MEMBERSHIP DUES. THE BILL DOES
BAN AGENTS FROM CONTRIBUTING,
WHILE A MATTER IS PENDING, WHICH
PARTIALLY ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM,
BUT THE BILL ALSO REMOVES LONG
STANDING AGGREGATION RULES,
WHICH MEANS THAT THE RESULTS OF
LEGAL ACTION COULD ALLOW PARTIES
TO MULTIPLY THEIR IMPACT THROUGH
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM MULTIPLE
AGENTS. WE CAN ALL IMAGINE THIS
REALITY, CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
ARE CHOOSING BETWEEN TWO
APPLICATIONS TO PROVIDE A RUN OF
THE MILL SERVICE IN THEIR CITY.
FOR EXAMPLE, TWO SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE COMPETING TO RUN
A CAMP STORE AT A POPULAR CITY
CAMPGROUND. OR THERE ARE TWO
APPLICANTS WHO WANT TO OPEN A
CANNABIS STORE IN A DESIGNATED
LOCATION. OFTEN, WHEN ONE OF
THOSE APPLICANT HOPEFULS DONATES
$1,000 TO EACH ELECTED OFFICIAL,
AND BECAUSE OF AGGREGATION
RULES, THE RESULT IS SEVERAL
THOUSANDS OR MULTIPLE THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FROM
ONE ENTITY. IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE
THAT THE PUBLIC WOULD BELIEVE
THAT THOSE DONATIONS HAVE NO
EFFECT ON DECISION MAKING. I
EVALUATE THIS BILL USING THE
LENS OF PRINCIPLES THAT I
BELIEVE ARE BROADLY SHARED. ONE,
I THINK WE DON'T WANT LARGE
FINANCIAL CONTRIBUTIONS TO
INFLUENCE DECISIONS ABOUT
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. WE WANT LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS MAKING
DECISIONS IN SUPPORT OF THE
PUBLIC GOOD, NOT BECAUSE OF
THEIR OWN PERSONAL FINANCIAL
ADVANTAGE IN THE NEXT ELECTION.
I THINK WE WANT COMPLIANCE WITH
THE LAW TO BE EASY TO UNDERSTAND
AND WORKABLE FOR BOTH THE
ELECTED OFFICIAL AND THE
POTENTIAL DONOR. WE WANT THE
RULES TO BE PRACTICAL. WE DON'T
WANT PEOPLE VOLUNTEERING THEIR
TIME SERVING ON BOARDS OR PART
TIME CITY COUNCILS TO HAVE TO
HIRE AN ATTORNEY TO DETERMINE
WHETHER SOMEONE CAN GIVE THEM A
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION. ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, THE
AVERAGE FOR CITIES CONTRIBUTION
LEVEL IS $500. WE WANT TO AVOID
GIANT LOOPHOLES WHERE THE
MAXIMUM CONTRIBUTION COULD BE
MADE MULTIPLE TIMES, ONCE BY THE
COMPANY SEEKING THE PERMIT, THEN
BY EACH AND EVERY OTHER AGENT
THE COMPANY HIRES THAT ADVOCATE
FOR THE PERMIT. WE WANT THE
RULES TO APPLY TO ALL DONORS
EQUALLY. NO CARVE OUTS OR
FAVORITES. I THINK WE WANT TO
HAVE CLEAR APPLICABILITY
TIMELINES SO SOMEONE KNOWS WHEN
THE PROHIBITION APPLIES AND WHEN
IT DOES NOT. I RECOGNIZE THAT
THE LAW, AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS,
NEEDS IMPROVEMENT. LIKE MANY OF
YOU, INCLUDING THE AUTHOR, I
HAVE RECEIVED FEEDBACK THAT THE
LAW NEEDS IMPROVEMENT AND
CLARIFYING. I WANT TO IMPROVE
IT. I THINK MANY OF US DO. THERE
ARE CURRENTLY TWO DIFFERENT
BILLS FROM DIFFERENT AUTHORS
THAT ARE ALSO AIMING TO MAKE
CHANGES TO THIS SAME LAW. THE
LEVINE ACT. IT'S WORTH REPEATING
HERE THAT WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT ARE THE RULES SURROUNDING
THE NARROW CIRCUMSTANCE OF AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL TAKING A
CONTRIBUTION FROM A PARTY THAT
IS ACTIVELY SEEKING AN APPROVAL
OR PERMIT FROM THAT SAME ELECTED
OFFICIAL. OTHER CONTRIBUTIONS
ARE NOT IMPLICATED AT ALL. AS
THE CHAIR OF ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS, I AM
STAYING OFF THIS BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT DOES NOT
FURTHER THE GOALS OF THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT AND DESPITE
QUITE ENOUGH TIME TO HAVE WORKED
THROUGH THE PROBLEMS, THE
PROBLEMS REMAIN. AND THE BILL AS
IT STANDS, IS A BILL THAT I
CANNOT SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS I
ARTICULATED. I WILL ALSO NOTE
THAT WHILE THERE HAVE BEEN
CONVERSATIONS, THE CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN AND COMMON CAUSE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
THEIR MOST IMPORTANT PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS HAVE NOT YET BEEN
ACCEPTED. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM, SENATOR
DODD, YOU MAY CLOSE. YES. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I JUST
THINK A COUPLE OF POINTS HERE
NEED TO BE NEED TO BE MADE.
FIRST OF ALL, IN THIS BODY, ANY
OF US CAN ACCEPT CONTRIBUTIONS
AT ANY GIVEN TIME, UP TO $5,500
AND MAKE A DECISION ON A VERY
IMPORTANT ITEM IN TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND SOMEBODY THAT
HAD A SPECIAL INTEREST, I FIRMLY
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT OUR LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR BY FOR $250. I DON'T
REALLY THINK THE WAY THE FPPC IS
RUN TODAY IS EVEN CAPABLE BEALL
OF DOING THIS. FRANKLY AND IF
YOU ARE PAY TO PLAY, THAT IS A
SUBJECT FOR A CITY ATTORNEY, A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY, AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, BECAUSE THAT
IS CORRUPTION. AND WE'VE SEEN IT
HAPPEN BEFORE AND THAT GET YOU
KNOW, THAT DOES WORK IN TERMS OF
THE LAW NEEDING IMPROVING. I
THINK IT DOES NEED SOME
IMPROVEMENT. AND ALREADY, JUST
IN THE SHORT PERIOD OF TIME THAT
I'VE RUN THIS THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE, YOU ALL SAW THAT
PROBABLY THE ARTICLE IN POLITICO
, IT'S NOT BEEN THAT MUCH TIME.
AND WE'VE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS. I BELIEVE THAT MY BILL
IS A GREAT VEHICLE GOING
FORWARD. AND, YOU KNOW ME OVER 9
OR 10 YEARS THAT I'M GOING TO
WORK THIS BILL AND GET THAT
DONE. THIS IS NOT ONLY
SUPPORTED. AND I THINK ONE OTHER
THING ON THE OPPOSITION TO ANY
OF THESE THINGS, LET'S SAY A
HOUSING SUBDIVISION, A
CONTRACTOR CAN ONLY RIGHT NOW
THE BILL CAN ONLY GIVE $250 TO
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL. NONE OF HIS
CONSULTANTS OR ANYBODY ELSE, YOU
KNOW, CAN GIVE ANYTHING BECAUSE
OF THE AGGREGATION RULES. AND
AND WHILE A BUNCH OF NIMBYS OF
500 HOMES THAT ARE ALL AROUND
THIS POTENTIAL SUBDIVISION CAN
ALL GIVE THE MAXIMUM
CONTRIBUTION ALLOWABLE BY LAW TO
THE OPPOSITION OAN I COMMIT TO
EVERY MEMBER IN THIS ROOM, I
WILL CONTINUE WORKING IN THIS
BILL. IT WILL EVIDENTLY IN NO
DOUBT IN MY MIND, CHANGE IN SOME
WAY SHAPE OR FORM, AND COME BACK
TO THIS BODY FOR CONCURRENCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEAR. NO. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD
LYMAN MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR
MEN. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO AYE. OCHOA. BORG. AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. SATO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
AYE WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN BECKER.
AYE. GLASER NO. LAIRD LIMON.
MENGIBAR MEN. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN WAHAB. AYES. 30 NOES.
TWO. MEASURE. PASSES AND THAT IS
ALL ON OUR SECOND THIRD READING.
MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE.
AMENDMENTS COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. THAT'S THE SECOND
TIME COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SENATOR MENGIBAR HAS BUDGETS UP
THREE IN ROOM 1200. IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING THIS, MEDIA FOLLOWING
SESSION. IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS. SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. MADAM
PRESIDENT, THANK YOU FOR SUCH A
SMOOTH AND EFFICIENT KICKOFF TO
HOUSE OF ORIGIN WEEK. THE GOAL
TODAY WAS 50 BILLS. WE ECLIPSED
THAT GOAL TOTAL MEASURES PASSED
TODAY 63. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
EACH OF THE SENATORS. WE ARE NOW
OFFICIALLY AHEAD OF SCHEDULE. AS
WE ALL KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING THE LATE SHIFT EACH AND
EVERY DAY. MEMBERS WILL BE
STARTING AT 10 A.M. TUESDAY,
WEDNESDAY, THURSDAY AND THEN
GOING LATE INTO THE EVENING EACH
OF THOSE NIGHTS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HARD WORK. THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
TUESDAY, MAY 21ST AT 10 A.M. THE
SENATE IS ADJOURNED. WE WILL
RECONVENE TUESDAY, MAY 21ST,
2024 AT 10 A.M.